THESE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISKS
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLICAN HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE TO SUPPRESSION.
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT.
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR SIX
SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT. I WILL
BE MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING TODAY AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
. WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
. TO COME TO THE SENATE CHAMBER
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM
AND BEGIN OUR HEARING. WE HAVE
FIFTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
THERE ARE THREE BILLS PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE. AND FILE A NUMBER FIFTEEN
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE. WE WILL DEAL WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND CORN WHEN
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
WE ARE WAITING FOR AUTHORS. IN
THAT EVENT- SENATOR NEWMAN I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU PICK UP
THE GAVEL AND THE WE TAKE UP-
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE. GLAD
TO DO IT NOW WELCOME CENTER RAS
GOING DIGITAL YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING ITEMS EIGHT TO TWELVE
TODAY LET'S BEGIN WITH THE FIRST
MEASURE SB FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE
. THANK YOU SIR SAID ABOUT
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE AUTHORIZES
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION TO
INCLUDE IN ORDER TO COMPENSATE
STUDENTS FOR HARM THAT RESULTED
OR MAY HAVE RESULTED. FROM
INSTITUTIONS VIOLATION IN A
CITATION. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
THE BIT THE BPP TO TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS BASED ON THE
SEVERITY OF AN INSTITUTION'S
VIOLATIONS AND THE HARM THAT
RESULTS OR MAY RESULT TO
STUDENTS. FROM THE INSTITUTION'S
VIOLATIONS THIS MEASURE BUILDS
ON THE EFFORTS UNDERTAKEN LAST
YEAR DURING THE SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT. AND CHANGES MADE IN
THE PERSON SAID BILL. SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE IS
INTENDED TO BE THE VEHICLE FOR
ADDITIONAL CHANGES TO THE ACT.
STEMMING FROM SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT WORK THROUGHOUT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. MOVING FORWARD THE MEASURE
WILL BE UPDATED TO REFLECT THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO ENSURE.
STUDENT SUCCESS AND QUALITY
EDUCATION WHILE RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR APPROPRIATE TRANSPARENT
REGULATION OF THE PROGRAMS.
OFFERING TRAINING AND EDUCATION
TO MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU THE BUREAU
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE AMEND THE ACT IN A
WAY THAT MAKES SENSE AND YIELDS
ARE. SHARED GOALS OF AFFORDABLE
MEANINGFUL EDUCATION WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I
VOTED THAT AT SUCH TIME AS WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU SIR WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT-
FIRST WE'LL HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
THIRTY MINUTES IS SURELY GOD
TESTIFIED. IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WHEN HE
TESTIFIED VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE- MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPOT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. THANK YOU AND MISS
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE US
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE THREE LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU TO PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND CALL THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES INDIVIDUAL
INDIVIDUALLY WILL GO FROM THERE
. THANK YOU MINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ANGELA PAIRING IT WITH THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS- EXPRESSING STRONG
SUPPORT THE BUREAU THIRTEEN
FINANCIAL FUNCTION FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE TO SERVING AS
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE FOR
STUDENTS WHO ENROLL IN PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY PROGRAMS. AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CHANGES
THAT WERE MADE IN THE BILL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING FURTHER
ON ADDITIONAL WAYS TO SUPPORT
THE BUREAU IN THIS TROUBLED TIME
THANK YOU. AGAIN SO MUCH
STRONGER. THE BILL. THANK YOU-
THIS MODERN NEXT WITNESS SUPPORT
PLEASE. LINE. THIRTY ONE THREE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE
ON THE LINE THIRTY SIX. THE
DAVID MARTIN ST. R. R. C. P. MHA
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL. NINE SIX TWO THANK YOU
OKAY WE ARE TAKING TESTS WHEN
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE- MISS MODERATOR ANY OTHER
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR SP
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE. NO NOT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON ANY
WITNESSES. WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SIGN A
PETITION JUST BEFORE TWO THIRTY
THREE. AND SEEING NONE- MISS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE-
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUAL WAITING TO
SIGN IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON. THANK YOU THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. BEGINNING INSTRUCTIONS ARE
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
FOR THAT WE WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO- THE- CHAMBER HERE- TO
ANY MEMBERS JOINING MEMBERS OF
COMMENTS AND SP FORTY THIRD.
I'VE GOT A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL- WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
AND- FROM SALIVA- AND WITH THAT
. I WOULD BE. WHAT DO YOU WANT.
WE HAVE A CORE ALL RIGHT- MADAM
CONSULTANT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE. RALPH RALPH HERE
MELENDEZ ARCHULETA- JULY DAY
HERE BEAT BACKER DADA A MAN.
EIGHT MEN HERE HER TADO JONES
JONES HERE AND LEAVE A- LEAVE
OUT HERE MAN. NEW MEN HERE
NEWMAN HERE HAND IN HERE. BACKER
BACKER HERE. AND I GATHER FROM
YOUR THUMBS UP BUSINESS WE DO OF
COURSE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A MOTION TO CENTER LAVER
AND SENATOR RALPH IF YOU LOOK
CLOSE. IS THIS FOR A VOTE. AND
MAN TO SOMEBODY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. F. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE DO YOU PASS IN A RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION ROTH. IRA ROTH IRA
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA ARCHULETA IB
. BACKER BACKER I DON. EGGMAN
EGGMAN I. HER TADO JONES JONES
I. LEIVA LEAVE THE ICEMAN NEWMAN
NINE NEWMAN I SHOW A BOGUS. HERE
IN CAN I. WE WILL PLACE THAT
MATTER ON CALL AND MOVE TO THE
NEXT BILL- IT IS FILE ITEM NINE
ALSO BY SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU
SOONER RATHER MOVE ON YOUR
SECONDBILL SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PROCEED. THANKS FOR
THIS BILL MAKE SUBSTANTIVE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE BOARD
OF CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS IN THE
CHIROPRACTIC LICENSEES UNDER ITS
JURISDICTION AS A RESULT OF THE
BOARD'S TWENTY TWENTY TWO SUNSET
REVIEW. THE BILL CURRENTLY
UPDATES TE INFORMATION REQUIRED
TO BE COLLECTED FOR THE
DIRECTORY OF LICENSEES. CREATED
BY THE STATE BOARD AND LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS WHICH WILL EXTEND
THE DATES FOR THE NEXT REVIEW OF
THE BOARD. TO JANUARY ONE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SEVEN REMOVE
UNNECESSARY EXEMPTIONS FOR
LICENSEES TO NOTIFY PATIENTS OF
THEIR PROBATIONARY STATUS. IF
THE LICENSE IS UNDER PROBATION
BY THE BOARD AND MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE DATES THE BOARD'S
RECORD REPORT A LICENSING FEE
RESTRUCTURE. I HAVE KRISTIN
WALKER WITH THE BOARD OF
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS AVAILABLE
ON THE LINE IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D REQUEST AND
I BOTH. AND THANK YOU SHANNON
WHAT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY WOULD LIKE
TO WISH LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR. SEEING NONE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MR
MODERATOR IF YOU'D PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR. WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN AS ONE AND
THEN ZERO PLEASE. THIS MONARCHY
PLEASE GIVE US A TOTAL OF NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO SIGN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET US NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS ANYBODY
HERE IN THE CHAMBER WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO SB. FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR. JANE ON
THAT LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE M. AS
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVDUALS WAITING TO SIGN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR- WE WILL HEAR THEIR TEST
ONE. THANK YOU THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. AND IF
YOU COULD PLEASE MODERATE LOW
SNOW. HOW MANY PEOPLE WE MAY
HAVE WAITING TO SIGN A PETITION
. THANK YOU TURN ONLINE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHTS SHE
NOTICES A BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I'VE GOT A MOTION
FROM SARASOTA TO MOVE THE BILL
ANY OTHER MEMBERS CAN ELECT TO
COMMENT. AT SERA D. LIKE CLOTHES
THE QUESTION I WROTE. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM CINDERELLA- MISS
MASON PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR DEEP PSSES
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RALPH. HI RALPH HI MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BE.
ACKER ACKER I DON A MAN A MAN HI
HER TADO JONES. JONES I'D LEAVE
THAT LEAVE ICEMEN NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN I UNTIL A BOGEY HAN. CAN
I. WE WILL PLACE THEM OUT ON
CALL AS WELL AND LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT AND FINAL ITEM TEN
ALSO BY THE CHAIRS AND ROTH-
XINHUA WHO MOVE ON YOUR THIRD
BILL SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
PLEASE PROCEED THANKS FOR THIS
BILL REFLECTS ISSUES DISCUSSED
AT THE MARCH SEVEN SUNSET REVIEW
HEARING BY EXTENDING THE
RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD SUNSET
DATE. JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY SEVEN AND REVISES
MANDATORY REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
WHICH WILL ONE CLARIFY WHO CANPERFORM RESPIRATORY CARE
SERVICES DURING A DECLARED STATE
OF EMERGENCY TO ALLOW LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSES TO PERFORM
RESPIRATORY CARE SERVICES WHEN
THEY RECEIVE TRAINING
SATISFACTORY TO THEIR EMPLOYER
AND WHEN DIRECTED BY A PHYSICIAN
AND SURGEON MAY PERFORM BASIC
RESPIRATORY TESTING SERVICES
THAT DO NOT REQUIRE THE
RESPIRATORY ASSESSMENT AND ONLY
REQUIRE MANUAL TECHNICAL SKILLS.
OR DATA COLLECTION AND THREE
HELLO LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSES
EMPLOYED BY A HOME HEALTH AGENCY
TO DO RESPIRATORY TESTING
SERVICES AGAIN A FIVE BY THE
BOARD IF THE LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSE HAS COMPLETED PATIENT
SPECIFIC TRAINING SATISFACTORY
TO THEIR EMPLOYER BEFORE JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IN
BEGINNING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE HAS COMPLETED
PATIENT SPECIFIC TRAINING BY THE
EMPLOYER IN ACCORDANCE WITH
GUIDELINES DEVELOPED. BY THE
RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE BOARD OF
OCCASIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS I HAVE
SEVEN NINE YEARS WITH THE
RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD AVAILABLE
ONLINE IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE POINT IN TIME I
RESPECTFULLY AS PART OF A DATA
CENTER- THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX FIRST LET'S HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERIES
ANYBODY HERE IN THE GALLERY WE
SHOULD TEST RUN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX YES. SHARE
MEMBERS JENNIFER TO. WITH ERIN
US. ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF FOR RESPIRATORY CARE
WE SUPPORT THE ESSENCE THAT
EXTENSION FOR THE RESPIRATORY
CARE BOARD AND LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS.
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR EMAILS OR
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE CHAMBER
WOULD LIKE TO SIGN SUPPORT. OF
SB FORTY THIRTY SIX.
YEAH. AND I THINK THE ANSWER IS
NO- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES YES. THERE IS THERE WE
DO IS PLEASE PLEASE PRETTY. SURE
NUMBER STILL NEEDS TO GOT IT
WITH A C. UNITED HEALTH CARE
WORKERS- WERE ACTUALLY A
TWEENER- BUT HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR AND STAFF
FOR THEIR CONTINUED WORK- ON
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
PRECIADO ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE PRESENCE OKAY ALL RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WHEN
DESCRIBING THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX IST
MODERATOR. THANK YOU EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. IF YOU
WOULD MIS ALL RIGHT LET US KNOW
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS MIGHT BE
WILLING TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU TO
HAVE ONE WITH AN OPERATOR STILL
I WILL INTRODUCE THEM IN JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
THAT SUPPORT COMMENT COMES FROM
THE LINE THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR IN THE-
BILL AT THREE NINE SIX ZERO IT
IS NOT THIS IS FOR S. P.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. MY
APOLOGIES JESSICA IS ANYBODY ON
THE TELECONFERENCE ON WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. NO
OTHER LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU LET US MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
ANYBODY HERE IN THE GALLERY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX IN PERSON SEEING NONE- MISS
MODERATOR IF YOU'D PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY RIDGES ON THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NO LINES IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET US BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE IS UNIQUE IN
ANY MEMBER COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT. ON THIS BILL. I'VE
GOT A MOTION FROM CENTER LAVER-
CENTER ALL OF WHICH YOU LIKE
CLOTHES. AS FOR NOW VOTE. NOW WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR CENTER LAVER-
MISTAKES IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIXTY PASSES AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH HI RALPH I
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
IB. BECKER BACKER I'D DIED A
MAN. HEY MAN I HEARD HATO. JONES
JONES I'D LEAVE US LEAVE I AM IN
. MAN HI NIMIN NINE NEWMAN I A
SHOW ABOUT OKAY HAND HERE AND I
WILL PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL AS
WELL AND WE WILL MOVE ON THE
FINAL ITEM- THE NEXT ITEM IS
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ALSO FROM CENTER ROTS AND
ROTH. PLEASE PROCEED THANKS FOR
THIS IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR INTERIOR
DESIGN CERTIFICATION. THE BILL
CURRENTLY THE LEAKS AND OUTDATED
PROVISION RELATED TO THE
COUNCIL'S REVIEW OF EXAMINATIONS
WHICH WAS COMPLETED MANY YEARS
AGO. I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT TO EXTEND
THE COUNCIL SUNSET THEY BUY FOR
YEARS TO JANUARY ONE. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SEVEN I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
VOLUNTARY INTERIOR DESIGN
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON THIS BILL. I AM A
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR INTERIOR
DESIGN CERTIFICATION AVAILABLE
ONLINE IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SIR RIGHT. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE THAT LET US MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE- WILL NOW
HEAR ANYWAY THIS IS GOING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IST
MODERATOR IF WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. AGAIN UP
TO ONE AND THEN A ZERO PLEASE.
IN THIS MATTER IF YOU COULD
PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. I BELIEVE WE JUST HAVE
THE ONE. THERE YOU GO AND THAT'S
THAT'S ROSAL WIRING. MISS
WHITING PLEASE PROCEED. CENTER
SHE'S AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS SO SHE OKAY DO NOT
PROCEED LET'S MOVE ON- TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SIGN IN PERSON
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. TWO NINE LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINES
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY CALLERS WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ME PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. AND THERE ARE NO
LINES IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR LET
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ON THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON THIS
BEFORE TWO THIRTY SEVEN. THE
MOTION FROM CENTER LASER.
ANYBODY ELSE NO QUESTION ROBIN
LIKE CLOTHES THANKS SIR PLEASE
OF OVERTIME. WITH A MOTION FOR
CENTER LIVE IN THIS NATION IF
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVENTY PASSES
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
ROTH. ROTH IRA MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA IB. BACKER
BACKER I'D DIED IN A MIN HEY MAN
I HEARD TADO JONES JONES I LEAVE
A- LEAVE A I. MIN. MIN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN I A SHOW ABOUT OKAY HANG
ON. HERE AND I- WE WILL PLACE IT
ON CALL AS WELL- AND NOW MOVE ON
TO I BELIEVE THE LAST OF THE
CHURCH BILLS- CENTER OFTEN RUN
TO YOUR LAST BILL SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED
THANKS FOR THIS BILL CURRENTLY
EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE IN THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY LAW AFTER THE
JOINT SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT.
OF THE PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA I ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
CHARTER AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS TO ENSURE THAT THE
BOARD CAN CONTINUE TO PERFORM
ITS DUTIES AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC BY EXTENDING ALL RELEVANT
SUNSET DATES IN STATUTE. I HAVE
JASON KAISER WITH PHYSICAL
THERAPY BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AND
BROOKE ARNESON WITH DCA
AVAILABLE ONLINE IF THERE ARE
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU SIR-
WILL NOW HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
THE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. AND SEEING NONE- AS
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE ON. ANYWAY
THIS IS WHAT HE TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO JOIN THE
COMMENT Q. AND IF YOU IF YOU
HAVE ONE PERSON WITH AN OPERATOR
YOU JUST MOM VERY GOOD.
WE HAVE LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHEESY ERRORS WITH THE
ANIMAL PHYSICAL THERAPY
COALITION AND- WE ARE. TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
AN OFFICE OF A THERAPY HAS BEEN-
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED FOR MORE THAN
A DECADE IN CALIFORNIA AND- THE
ANIMAL TO SQUARE THE COALITION
ASSET SP FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
BE AMENDED TO AUTHORIZE. A
CALIFORNIA LICENSED PHYSICAL
THERAPIST WITH ADVANCED
CERTIFICATION ANIMAL PHYSICAL
THERAPY TO PROVIDE- ANIMAL
PHYSICAL REHABILITATION UNDER
THE DEGREE OF SUPERVISION TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE VETERINARIAN
WHO WAS ESTABLISHED A
VETERINARIAN CLIENT PATIENT.
RELATIONSHIP THE VETERINARY
PREMISE OR AN ANIMAL PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION PREMISE OR RANGE
SETTING- WE REALIZE THAT THIS IS
NOT ONLY DEALING WITH THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY FOR BUT ALSO
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD AND
THIS IS AN ONGOING ISSUE- WE
WOULD SUPPORT BILL FOLEY YEAH-
IF THE WORK NEEDED TO. REFLECT
SUCH A MOMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR SYSTEMS MODERATE IF YOU
COULD CALL ONE MORE TIME SINCE
ANYBODY ON THE TELECONFERENCE ON. IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IF ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO STATE. FOR THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN THE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER'S ANYBODY HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. IN PERSON WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- TO SB
FORTY THREE. SEEING NONE OF LET
US GO BACK TO THE TELECONFERENCE
I MISSED MY REVIEW COULD PULL.
THE CONFERENCE ON IS ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTY. FOUR THANK YOU
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
OF FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. WE
HAVE NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO CHAMBERS
ANYBODY HERE ON THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. I'VE
SAID DR THANK YOU IT'S JUST A
QUESTION ABOUT THE ONE OF THE
FIRST AUTHOR AMENDMENTS WHICH
WAS SAID TWO POINT EXACTLY WHAT
EXEMPTS FROM PROVISIONS OF STATE
CIVIL SERVICE ACT. WHAT DOES NOT
CLARIFY THE REASON FOR EXEMPTING
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER FROM THE
CIVIL SERVICE ACT. I'VE BEEN
INFORMED THAT ALL OF THE
EMPLOYEES ARE EXEMPT AS
PHYSICIANS. OKAY ALL EMPLOYEES
OF THIS BORDER ALL BOARDS ARE
EXEMPT FROM CIVIL SERVICE ACT.
CAN YOU ACTUALLY GET. BUT.
OKAY. OKAY ALL RIGHT AT A VERY
BRIEF I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER-
YOU KNOW THE ONE REASONS I RAISE
THE QUESTION IS JUST THAT- YOU
TOO MANY TIMES AGENCIES HAVE
REQUESTED- PARTICULAR. A
RESIDENT AGENCIES TO BE EXEMPT
FROM CIVIL SERVICE ACT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ACTUALLY PAYMENT
SALLY STILL DIFFERENT THAN THE
CIVIL SERVICE SALARY SCALE. AND
TWELVE THAT MAY BE NECESSARY AT
TIMES I THINK THAT ALSO RAISES
THE QUESTION IF THAT HAPPENS SO
FREQUENTLY THAT WE NEED TO
REVISIT THE CIVIL SERVICE SALARY
SCALE AS WE CAN BE COMPETITIVE
AS A STATE. SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT BUT- I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER DOES NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE AT THE- PLEASURE OF THE
BOARD. ITSELF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. IN ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF TWENTY HAVE. MORE
QUESTIONS AND LEAVE HER EMOTIONS
FROM. GENERATION LETTER. NINE
ZERO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. IS
THIS FOR ANOTHER VOTE WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM CENTER TO LEAD IN
THIS NATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT DO YOU PROCESS AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ROTH. IRA ROTH IRA
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D BE. BACKER DODD DONNA HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN HI HER TADO. JONES
JONES I LLEVA LEAVE A I A MAN.
MIN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I SHOW A
BOGUS. HAN HAN I. THANK YOU MR
TURNING IT BACK THE GAVEL BACK
TO. IN ORDER TO HOLD THE ROLE
OPENS THANK YOU SENATOR MAN-
LET'S TAKE UP THE CONSENT FILED
OUT OF STEP DIRECTOR IF YOU'RE
PREPARED TO DO SO. MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO REMIND YOU TO PLEASE I
AM SPEAK INTO YOUR MICROPHONE
YOU'RE VOTING THAT CONSENT FILE
FOR TODAY'S HEARING IS FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AS B. FOURTEEN FORTY.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AS B.
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE AND FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN SB FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE. OF COURSE SIR- MOTION ON
CONSENT. I DIDN'T CATCH THAT
CENTER LEFT CENTER I'VE BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER BACK. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. RALPH HI RALPH HI
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA ARCHULETA IV
BACKER. DOT DONNA HI EGGMAN
EGGMAN HI HER TADO HER TADO I'D
JONES JONES I. LEIVA LEVI MEN
MEN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I CHOSE
BOTH. HE CAN HE CAN I. HOLD THE
ROPE INFRACTION MEMBERS NOT TO
ARE VERY VERY PATIENT COLLEAGUE
SENATOR JONES ILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THANK YOU SENATOR JONES FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'LL BE PRESENTING- SP
NINE SIXTY TWO. WHICH ENSURES
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
WHO MEET THE COLLEGE OF AMERICAN
PATHOLOGISTS STANDARDS MAY WORK
AS LABORATORY DIRECTORS AND
TECHNICAL CONSULTANTS IN
MODERATE. COMPLEXITY
LABORATORIES. CALIFORNIA'S
REQUIREMENTS FOR LABORATORY
PERSONNEL LICENSURE HAVE BECOME
A BARRIER FOR OTHERWISE
QUALIFIED PROFESSIONALS AS
DEFINED BY THE COLLEGE OF
AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS
REQUIREMENTS. RESPIRATORY CARE
PRACTITIONERS ARE TRAINED AND
LICENSED TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE
BLOOD GASES AND RESPIRATORY
SECRETIONS. JUST AS IS NECESSARY
IN MODERATE COMPLEXITY
LABORATORIES. EARLIER THIS YEAR
THERE WERE OVER TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND RESPIRATORY CARE
PRACTITIONERS IN CALIFORNIA ANY
OF WHOM COULD QUALIFY TO BE
TECHNICAL CONSULTANT ACCORDING
TO C. P. STANDARDS ASSUMING THEY
HOLD  REQUIRED
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. THIS BILL
UPDATE THE DEFINITIONS OF
LABORATORY DIRECTOR AND
TECHNICAL CONSULTANTS TO INCLUDE
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
THAT MEET THE CAP STANDARDS.
THIS CHANGE WILL PROVIDE CAREER
ADVANCEMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS INDIVIDUALS ALREADY
WORKING IN BUT BLOOD GAS LABS AS
REGULAR TESTING PERSONNEL AND
HELP FILL THE CURRENT GAP IN
QUALIFIED PERSONNEL FOR THOSE
LABORATORIES. I'VE GOT TO- AS
SOME FOLKS ON THE LINE THEY'RE
AVAILABLE FOR- QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS AND I
THINK SOME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU SENATOR WE GENERALLY
LIMITS EACH SIDE TO A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES I'LL TRY TO HOLD
YOU TO THAT HERE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
JENNIFER TANNEHILL AND DOCTOR
GERALD DIVERSITY IF I PRONOUNCE
THAT CORRECTLY. HERE AS LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER TANNER HILL WITH THE
ERIN READ IT SAYS IT'S ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY FOR
RESPIRATORY CARE. BUT I THINK
THE- THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US IN THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
FOR WORKING WITH US. TO GET SOME
GOOD AMENDMENTS INTO THE BILL. A
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
ALSO KNOWN AS RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS WORK WITH VULNERABLE
PAPER PATIENT POPULATIONS FROM
INFANTS TO THE ELDERLY R. CP'S
HAVE SPECIALIZED TRAINING IN
CARDIOLOGY AND PULMONOLOGY THEY
WORK WITH PATIENTS IN INTENSIVE
CARE UNITS OPERATING ROOMS
OUTPATIENT CLINICS. SLEEP
CLINICS LABORATORIES AND HOME
HEALTH ENVIRONMENTS EVEN IN
HELICOPTERS TRANSPORTING
CRITICALLY ILL PATIENTS AND
MANAGING THE PATIENT'S AIRWAY.
MOST RECENTLY R. C. P.'S WORK ON
THE FRONT LINES BATTLING CODE
NINETEEN FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO BREATHE. IT IS
MORE THAN APPROPRIATE TO ALLOW
R. CP'S WHO MEET THE REST OF THE
COLLEGE OF AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS
REQUIREMENTS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LAB DIRECTOR AND TECHNICAL
CONSULTANT POSITIONS. IN THE
MODERATE COMPLEXITY LABS IN
WHICH THEY WORK IN HOSPITALS
THESE LABS ARE OFTEN LOCATED IN
THIS RESPIRATORY CARE
DEPARTMENT. DUE TO THE NATURE OF
THE WORK WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
I'LL GIVE THE REST OF MY TIME TO
DOCTORS OF OR SKI. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M GERALD
DIVORCE SKI I HAVE A PHD IN
EXPERIMENTAL MEDICINE AND I HAVE
A LICENSE TO PRACTICE
RESPIRATORY CARE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ILLINOIS. I HAVE PUBLISHED
SEVERAL PEER REVIEWED SCIENTIFIC
ARTICLES ON BLOOD GASES AND
ELECTROLYTES AND LACTATE
STABILITY FOR THE LAST TWO AND A
HALF YEARS I WORKED IN THE BLOOD
GAS LAB AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS. THE LAB IS
CONSIDERED MODERATELY COMPLEX
BASED ON SEVEN CRITERIA FROM THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR REGULATIONS.
WHEN I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I DID NOT
REALIZE HOW LIMITING THE CURRENT
LAWS ARE FOR LABORATORY
PERSONNEL. IT IS DISHEARTENING
THAT SOMEONE WITH A PHD IN A
LICENSE TO PRACTICE RESPIRATORY
CARE. WITH NUMEROUS PUBLICATIONS
IN THE SCIENTIFIC FIELD DOES NOT
QUALIFY AS A TECHNICAL
CONSULTANT. IN A MODERATE
COMPLEXITY LAB. HOWEVER CLINICAL
LABORATORY SCIENTIST WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE ARE ELIGIBLE
AS TECHNICAL CONSULTANTS IN
CALIFORNIA. A TECHNICAL
CONSULTANT ISA VITAL LABORATORY
POSITION SINCE THEY PERFORM
YEARLY COMPETENCY CHECK OFFS FOR
LAB PERSONNEL. TO MAINTAIN LAB
ACCREDITATION. IT HAS BEEN
HIGHLY FRUSTRATING NOT TO
PERFORM THIS THIS KIND OF JOB
THAT I WAS INITIALLY HIRED FOR.
THE FEDERAL CLEAR REGULATIONS
REQUIRE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE WITH
RELEVANT EXPERIENCE AS A
LABORATORY DIRECTOR OF A
MODERATE COMPLEXITY LAB. THIS
BILL SB NINE SIXTY TWO GOES
BEYOND THE KLIA BY REQUIRING THE
MORE STRINGENT COLLEGE OF
AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS GUIDELINES
FOR LABORATORY PERSONNEL
LICENSURE. THE COLLEGE OF
AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS GUIDELINES
REQUIRE A LABORATORY DIRECTOR TO
HAVE A DOCTORATE IN A BIOLOGICAL
SCIENCE AMONG OTHERS AND ONE
YEAR EXPERIENCE IN LAB
SUPERVISION. ANOTHER PATH TO LAB
DIRECTORSHIP IS A MEDICAL
LICENSE AND ONE YEAR A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE. TO BE CONSIDERED A
TECHNICAL CONSULTANT THE COLLEGE
OF AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS REQUIRE
THE SAME BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND
TWO YEARS OF LAB EXPERIENCE ALL
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
ARE TRAINED IN BLOOD SAMPLING
ANALYSES INTERPRETATION. AND IT
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO EITHER THE
TECHNICAL CONSULTANTS OR
LABORATORY DIRECTOR POSITIONS IF
THEY MEET THE COLLEGE OF
AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS STANDARDS.
DATA FROM THE RESPIRATORY CARE
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA SHOW THAT
ABOUT 30% OF ALL RESPIRATORY
CARE PRACTITIONERS HAVE AT LEAST
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE. SIX MILLION
SEVEN THOUSAND THERAPISTS OF
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
PRACTITIONERS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENTS AS TECHNICAL
CONSULTANTS IN MODERATE
COMPLEXITY LABS IF THE COLLEGE
OF AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS
GUIDELINES ARE FOLLOWED. ABOUT
ONE HUNDRED RESPIRATORY CARE
PRACTITIONERS WOULD ALSO QUALIFY
AS LABORATORY DIRECTORS IN THE
STATE. THUS THIS BILL SB NINE
SIXTY TWO WOULD ALLOW CAREER
ADVANCEMENT AND HELP BLOOD GAS
LABS HOUSE IN RESPIRATORY CARE
DEPARTMENTS COMPLY WITH
ACCREDITATION REQUIREMENTS
FURTHERMORE THE LANGUAGE DOES
NOT DILUTE CALIFORNIA STANDARDS
SINCE PRACTITIONERS ARE TRAINED
IN BLOOD GAS ANALYSES AND MUST
MEET THE COLLEGE OF AMERICAN
PATHOLOGISTS GUIDELINES IT IS
FOR THIS REASONS THESE REASONS.
THAT I REQUEST YOUR I VOTE I AM
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR TELL US HERE
FOR MANY OTHER WITNESSES- IN THE
GALLERY IF THERE ARE ANY. I SEE
NONE LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT. ANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS WAY AND TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
SIX TWO. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. IN THAT
COMMAND IS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE SEVEN LINES IN
Q. PLEASE PERSONAL PURSE THANK
YOU THE LINE TWELVE. THANK YOU
TERM NUMBER BEAR BRIDGE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. LINE THIRTY SIX. DAVID MARTIN
ST R. C. P. V. EIGHT MHA THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE SUPPORT
THE SENATE BILL NINE SIX TWO
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. NINE
OF. NINETEEN HI MY NAME IS MANDY
FAN I CURRENTLY WORKING AS
DIRECTOR CARE PRACTITIONER AT UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF BILL NINE SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT. THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS THAT MEGAN
HODGE I'M AN ART THE P. I. E. C.
DAVIS. AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SIX TWO. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT PLEASE. ONLINE. TWENTY LINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELCOME TO A LINE THIRTY TWO.
YEAH. PLEASE PROCEED. NINE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT PLEASE LINE. THIRTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN ROBIN
MEMBERS I AM STEPPING IN AS
EXECUTIVE OFFICER DIRECTED
TOWARDS AIRPORT OUR BOARD FULLY
SUPPORTS THE NC NINE SIX TWO
WHICH REMOVES UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS AND ALIGNED EDUCATION
AND EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS WITH
KOREA AND THE COLLEGE OF
AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS STANDARDS
FOR THOSE QUALIFIED TO SERVE AS
A LABORATORY DIRECTOR OR
TECHNICAL CONSULTANT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BLIND.
TWENTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
REBECCA CORRECT IN ADDITION
INTERCONNECT IN A VERSATILE
TWENTY DAVIDSON DIVISION
DIRECTOR- I WORKED VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE RESPIRATORY THERAPIST-
BUT CLINICALLY AND DOING
RESEARCH AND FEEL VERY STRONGLY
THAT THE SPELL I THINK THAT
THEY'RE MORE THAN CAPABLE AND
WILL PROVIDE ON ANOTHER LEVEL
OF. QUALITY FOR OUR PATIENTS.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE LINE.
FORTY FIVE. HI THERE MY NAME IS
KATHERINE SHALOM AND THE BEST
BETWEEN CARE PRACTITIONER IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA BUT GUESS
WHAT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THE LINE
FORTY SIX. NINE FORTY SIX IS OUR
FINAL LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT PLEASE TURN OFF FOR ME NOT
FOR THE LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FOR MANY OPPOSITION FIRST
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. MODERATOR FEUD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUALS WHEN
THEY TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL NINE SIX TWO. WE
WILL PROCEED MAKING. THANK YOU
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THERE
ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
LET'S BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE CHAMBERS AND MY COLLEAGUES
HERE COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. ABOUT
SENATE BILL NINE SIX TWO
DOCTRINE. THANK YOU- AND
SYNERGIZE APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THE BILL FORD AND CERTAINLY MADE
A COMPELLING CASE FOR- FOR RC
PIECE I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
THAT UNDER YEAH AND NOW SAYS
UNDER POLICY CONSIDERATIONS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BILL ITSELF
. IS BROADER THAN JUST R. C.
P.'S- SO IS THE END IS YOUR
INTENT TO GIVEN THE FACT ALL THE
TESTIMONY AND THE ARGUMENTS ARE
MADE SPECIFICALLY AROUND.
RESPITE CARE- NATIONALS ARE THAT
WE'RE GONNA NARROW THE BILL TO
THE R. C. PEAS ARE- SINCE WE
HAVEN'T REALLY HEARD ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE ASIDE FROM OUR CITIES WHO
CLEARLY I THINK HAVE MADE IT
YEAH I MADE A CASE FOR THEIR-
THEIR THEIR ROLE AND BEING A
LAB. LED A TECHNICAL CONSULTANT
. SIR JOHN THANK YOU DOCTOR CAN-
MAYBE A LEAD TIME IS TEN HE'LL
TAKE A SHOT ANSWER THAT QUESTION
FOR YOU. THE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER CAN I HELP-
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION DOCTOR
PAN. AT THIS TIME BUT WE WERE
FOCUSED ON RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST- BUT WE CAN TALK ABOUT
HOW WE WANT TO NARROW THE BILL
IF THE LANGUAGE DOESN'T REFLECT
THAT ACCURATELY. THANK YOU MA'AM
OKAY- FAN SO IS THAT THE INTENT
OF THE AUTHORS YES THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY THAT THAT THANK YOU
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT- BECAUSE-
AGAIN- YEAH- I THINK. GIVEN THE
TESTIMONY IN THE ARGUMENTS MADE
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC- CERTAINLY
THAT MAKES SENSE BUT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT JUST BROADENING
IT TO OTHER OTHER OTHER PEOPLE
WHO- WE HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT
SOMETHING I THINK YOU. CALLING
THE OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SAYING NO MIKE'S UP.
SIR JOHN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I THANK YOU FOR THE ENGAGEMENT
OF MEMBERS AND I ASK FOR MY VOTE
. WE HAVE A MOTION ON SENATE
BILL NINE SIX TWO. SEARCH A LOT
OF MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS REFERRED THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS MADAM STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
F. B. NINE SIXTY TWO DO YOU PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH BY RALPH I
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCH A LOT
I BEAT. BACKER BACKER EYED
DAUGHTER DONNA HI AIKMAN HEY MAN
I HEARD TADO- TADO I'D JONES
JONES I. LEIVA. LEAVE THE ICEMEN
MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN I H. O.
ABOGADOS HAN HE AND I. BILL HAS
ELEVEN VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS SIR
JONES. SENATE BILL NINE NINE
FOUR. THANK YOU MR CHAIR I'LL BE
PRESENTING SENATE BILL NINE
NINETY FOUR AND FIRST OFF I'D
LIKE TO START BY THINKING YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND I LIKE TO ACCEPTED
MEASUREMENTS ON PAGE NINE OF
DENOUNCES AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
SB NINE NINE FOUR ADDRESSES A
SMALL LIMITATION TO A NATURAL
PATH THAT DOCTORS CURRENT
ALLOWANCES. BY ALLOWING NATURAL
PATHAK DOCTORS TO HIRE LICENSED
VOCTIONAL NURSES CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT SPECIFICALLY PERMIT AN
LPN TO BE HIRED BY AN INDIE SO
THE WORKINGRELATIONSHIP CANNOT
BE ESTABLISHED HOWEVER LV IS
FREQUENTLY APPLIED TO WORKING IN
THE OFFICES IN INDIES ARE NOT
ABLE TO CONSIDER THEM FOR
EMPLOYMENT EVEN IF THAT L. THE
END WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE CARE OF
THE PRACTICES PATIENTS. HAVE AN
INDYCAR HIGHER LV AND IT WOULD
ALLOW FOR INCREASED EFFICIENCY
OF APPOINTMENTS INCREASING
AVAILABILITY FOR CERTAIN MEDICAL
PROCEDURES AND AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF LICENSED MEDICALLY
TRAINED SUPPORT STAFF IN THE
OFFICE WE WORK FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF IN THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION TO ENSURE
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE. FOR
EITHER INDIES OR LV ENDS WITH ME
IN THE GALLERY TODAY OR DOCTOR
LIZA CICERONE CURRENT PRESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA NATURAL CATHOLIC
DOCTORS ASSOCIATION AND DR
STEPHEN IN AGAIN THE INCOMING
PRESIDENT OF C. N. DA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR WITNESSES
PLEASE PROCEED. BUSINESSES
AROUND THE PRESENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL THINK DOCTORS
ASSOCIATION. I CURRENTLY RUN A
LARGE PRIVATE PRACTICE AND SO ON
THE BEACH. OF THE PRIOR TO MY
PRIVATE PRACTICE I WAS AN
ATTENDING DOCTOR BOTH INDIANA
UNIVERSITY HEALTH AND CANCER
TREATMENT CENTERS OF AMERICA. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION TODAY. IN OUR
ORIGINAL LICENSING BILL WE ASKED
FOR THE TITLE PHYSICIAN WHICH WE
USE IN SURROUNDING STATES BUT
AFTER CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CMA
AGREED TO THE TITLE OF DOCTOR
INSTEAD. THAT AGREEMENT HAD
BROAD IMPLICATIONS FOR HOW NOT
YOUR BROTHER DOCTORS ARE ABLE TO
PRACTICE IN THE PRIMARY CARE
SETTING DESPITE BEING LICENSED
AS INDEPENDENT PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS. THESE APPLICATIONS ARE
DUE TO LANGUAGE USING CODES
REGULATIONS NOT DUE TO THE
TRAINING AND QUALIFICATIONS OF
NATURAL CATHOLIC DOCTORS. S. B.
NINE AND FOUR ADDRESSES ONE OF
THESE LIMITATIONS BY ALLOWING
NATURAL PATHAK DOCTORS TO HIRE
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSES. AND
THESE ARE LICENSED IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
SCOPE OF PRACTICE ARE ABLE TO
PERFORM PHYSICAL EXAMS ORDER
LABORATORY TESTS AND IMAGING
DRAW BLOOD. PERFORM CLEARLY
LABORATORY TESTING IN OFFICE AND
ADMINISTER IV USING INJECTIONS.
WE ARE TRAINED AT FOUR YEAR
POSTGRADUATE NATURAL PATHAK
MEDICAL SCHOOLS WE TAKE NATIONAL
LICENSING EXAMS ARE HELD TO THE
SAME SAFETY STANDARDS AS OUR MD
AND DO COLLEAGUES. WITH AN
EXCELLENT SAFETY RECORD THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE SCOPE
OF PRACTICE FOR ANDY'S OR FOR LV
ENDS THE WORK THAT CAN BE DONE
IS ONLY AT THE INTERSECTION OF
THEIR EXISTING SCOPES. HAVING
THE ABILITY TO HIRE ONLY ENDS AS
IMPORTANT STEP TO IMPROVING
ACCESS. IN THE EXPERIENCE OF
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY TO THE MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO CHOOSE AND USE
FOR THEIR PRIMARY CARE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE NINE FOUR.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. HELLO
GERMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOCTOR STEPHEN MANHATTAN
I AM THE CURRENT VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
DOCTORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CLINICAL DIRECTOR OF CEDAR
SINAI'S INTEGRATIVE MEDICINE
PROGRAM. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME REAL
WORLD IMPACTS AT S. B. NINE AND
FOUR WOULD HAVE ON THE PATIENTS
THAT WE CARE FOR. AND I WORK AT
CEDARS SINAI I HAVE FIRST HAND
IMPACTS I SEE IT SEE THE FIRST
HAND IMPACTS OF NOT BEING ABLE
TO GIVE ORDERS TO LV ENDS. MANY
OF MY ND COLLEAGUES- WORK
ALONGSIDE MEDICAL DOCTORS AND
OSTEOPATHIC OSTEOPATHIC DOCTORS
LIKE MYSELF. AND ROB TO
PROVIDING CARE AS PART OF AN
INTEGRATED TEAM WITH WHOM WE
SHARE PATIENTS AND COORDINATE
CARE. NOT BEING ABLE TO GIVE
ORDERS TO LV ENDS CREATES A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
REDUNDANCY FOR MYSELF. MY
PHYSICIAN COLLEAGUES. AND CEDAR
SINAI STAFF. PROVIDES
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO CARE FOR
OUR PATIENTS- REGULATIONS WHEN
L. V. N. AND OUR OFFICE IS
DELIVERING CARE PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO A PATIENT
REGARDING THEIR TREATMENT PLAN.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO REFER TO
ANY CONTRIBUTIONS THAT I HAVE
MADE TO THEIR WELLNESS PLAN. IN
THIS SITUATION THE PHYSICIAN HAS
TO EITHER REPEAT ALL MY
TREATMENT RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THEIR OWN PLAN. OR TMS TO USE AN
ADDITIONAL SEPARATE STAFF MEMBER
AND AUTOMATIC ASSISTANT TO RELAY
INFORMATION TO OUR MUTUAL
PATIENT. IN OTHER INSTANCES WHEN
I'M NOT IN THE OFFICE BUT A
PATIENT COMES IN TO RECEIVE AN
INJECTION THAT I PRESCRIBE FOR
THEM. OR SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS
A BLOOD PRESSURE CHECK WE HAVE
TO EITHER RESCHEDULE THE PATIENT
OR HOPE THAT ONE OF THE OTHER
POSITIONS IN THE OFFICE HAS TIME
TO GIVE NEW ORDERS TO OUR STAFF.
THEIR IMPACTS ON PATIENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE OFFICE SETTING AS
WELL. IT IS VITAL FOR LPNS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ORDERS FROM ANY
DOCTOR WHO IS PRESCRIBING
TREATMENTS FOR SOMEONE UNDER
THEIR CARE. REGARDLESS OF WHO
HIRED THEM. WHEN WE HAVE
PATIENTS REQUIRING IN HOME CARE
FROM LV ENDS OR WHEN PATIENTS
HAVE TRANSITIONED INTO CARE
HOMES. L. BRANDS ARE NOT ABLE TO
ADMINISTER ANY TREATMENT
PRESCRIBED BY THEIR ANTI. UNDER
CURRENT REGULATIONS SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS A MULTI VITAMIN CANNOT
BE GIVEN BY AN LPN TO A PATIENT
UNDER THEIR CARE IF IT WAS
PRESCRIBE AN ANTI. ULTIMATELY SB
NINE AND FOUR WOULD IMPROVE
PATIENT ACCESS TO CARE REDUCE
THEIR WAIT TIMES. AND ALLOW FOR
BETTER CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR TIME OF
NEED. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB NINE AND
FOUR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU DOCTOR LET'S
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE OF ITS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE. PROPERTIES
SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL NINE NINE FOUR. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
WHICH YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE LINE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT AS AN OPERATOR
PRESSES THE LINE.
OUR COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WORK AT
COMMERCIAL. DIRECTOR WITH THE
NATIONAL CAPITAL COMMITTEE AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. COMMITTEE
ISN'T FULL SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
NINE NINETY FOUR AND BELIEVES
THIS WILL REMOVE CURRENT
BARRIERS WE- AND RESOLVE THE
CHALLENGES IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSUMER ACCESS.
WE ALSO LOOKED AT THE NINE NINE
FORMAL NOT PRIVATE PRACTICE
DOCTOR ET AND D. OR L. B. N. AND
THAT THAT ALSO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL LAYER HE IN THE
OFFICE THANKS. FOR GOING RESET
HIGHLIGHTED TODAY HERE IN FRONT
OF NINETY NINE NINETY FOUR AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT AS. WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NOT
FOR THE LINE YOU FOR. THANK YOU
MISS MODERATOR NOW IT'S THE
SAME. IN HERE FROM OPPOSITION
WENT FOR WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT. ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
NINE NINE FOUR WE WILL PROCEED
WITH THEM. THANK YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AGAINST THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. WE HAVE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR NOW LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL. I SEE NO MIKE'S
UP FEDERAL LABOR'S MOVED THE
BILL SENATOR JONES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR EVERY SPECIALLY ASKED THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR I VOTE.
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE RLL. F. B. NINE NINE FOUR
DEEP PASSES AMENDED AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH HI RALPH I
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCH A LOT
I BEAT BACKER. BACKER BACKER I'D
DIED IN DOT I A MAN EIGHT MIN I
HER TADO FURTADO I'D JONES HI.
JONES I. LEIVA LEAVE I AM IN
MAINE I NEWMAN NEWMAN I ENSURE
VOGUE HAN. THE BILL HAS TEN
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR- ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR
COVER EURO. YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING- SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU MR CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING KEREN MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE CROSS JURISDICTIONAL
IMPORT AND EXPORT TO OTHER
STATES OF CANNABIS AND CANNABIS
PRODUCTS GROWN AND PRODUCED IN
CALIFORNIA BY AUTHORIZING THE
GOVERNOR TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT TO PROVIDE LAWFUL
INTERSTATE COMMERCE. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO THE NATION'S OLDEST
AND LARGEST CANNABIS INDUSTRY IN
THE US WITH WIDE KANNST
CONSENSUS THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES MORE CANNABIS THEY CAN
THEN IT CONSUMES HISTORICALLY
MOST OF THE CANNABIS GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA WAS EXPORTED UP 280%
BY SOME ESTIMATES AND THIS
PROHIBITION HAS CONSEQUENTLY
LEFT MANY CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
PRODUCERS. LEGAL CANNABIS
PRODUCERS WITH NO VIABLE PATHWAY
INTO THE LEGAL REGULATED MARKET.
WITHOUT CONSIDERABLE MARKET
EXPANSION IS ONE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO STABILIZE THE LEGAL
INDUSTRY AND MISTER CHAIR I KNOW
YOU AND I HAVE SAT THROUGH
HEARINGS WHERE WE TALK ABOUT A
MYRIAD OF ISSUES WITH- CANNABIS
AND PART OF THAT ISSUES ARE ARE
TAXING NO QUESTION ABOUT IT-
THIS DOESN'T DEAL WITH THAT BUT-
ONE OF THIS IS A PARTIAL
SOLUTIONS. TO STABILIZE THE
LEGAL INDUSTRY AND INCENTIVIZE
PARTICIPATION IN THE REGULATED
MARKET HELLO- IS THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA WRIST THE CLASS
COLLAPSE THE PORTIONS OF THE
LEGAL INDUSTRY. THIS WOULD TAKE
US BACKWARDS AND WOULD RESULT IN
CONSIDERABLE EXPANSION OF THE
ILLICIT MARKET IN CALIFORNIA S.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX WOULD
PROVIDE A MECHANISM FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PERMIT PROSPEROUS
FICTIONAL CANNABIS COMMERCE WITH
ANY STATE THAT HAS LEGALIZED
CANNABIS USE. CALIFORNIA HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN A NET EXPORTER
OF CANNABIS AND S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX WILL DEMONSTRATE
CALIFORNIA'S WILLINGNESS TO
LEGALLY SUPPLIED CANNABIS TO
OTHER STATES WHO HAVE
TRADITIONALLY IMPORTED THESE
PRODUCTS ILLEGALLY. AND PRESENT
PRESENTLY HAVE DIFFICULTY
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THEIR LEGAL
OUR- THE PROPOSED INTER INTER
STATE CANNABIS ACTIVITIES MUST
BE LAWFUL AND SUBJECT TO
LICENSORS UNDER BOTH OF THE
STATE THE LOSS OF BOTH OF THE
STATE. S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
REQUIRES THE AGREEMENT TO
INCLUDE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
. LABELING STANDARDS A SYSTEM TO
REGULATE AND TRACK CANNABIS-
COLLECTION OF APPLICABLES TAXES
ALL THE RULES THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS PUT IN PLACE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
ANY OUT OF STATE CANNABIS ITEMS
DELIVERED TO CALIFORNIA WOULD
NEED TO BE TESTED PACKAGED AND
LABELED IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW. SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX PROVIDES A
RELIEF VALVE FOR THE OVER SUPPLY
OF CANNABIS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GROW CALIFORNIA'S BRAND AND
MARKET SHARE WOULD SUPPORT JOB
CREATION AND GIVES THE STATE A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE AS FEDERAL. TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
FULLY CAPITALIZE ON AND REMAIN A
LEADER IN THE FORTHCOMING
NATIONAL CANNABIS MARKET I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS OF THE BILL
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD
TODAY I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS TO
DEVELOP AN APPROPRIATE MECHANISM
TO ENSURE THE LEGISLATURE'S
INVOLVEMENT. IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE INTERSTATE AGREEMENT
UNDER THIS BILL WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
IS LAUREN FRAZIER SHE'S FROM THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION SHE WILL BE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND SERRA
DOCKET FROM RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WHO IS PRESENT. AT THE HEARING.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES JUST AS A
REMINDER EACH SIDE WILL ONLY BE
PERMITTED A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS AND THE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE PARTICULAR BILL- MISS
FRASIER CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION.
PROBLEM IS ONE OF THE RARE. GOOD
MORNING IRAQ AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ONE RADAR FOUNDING
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION OF BOTH THE ASIAN
HERE TECHNICAL SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX.
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR EXPORT TO
LEGAL MARKET WHERE THERE HAVE
BEEN A DEMAND FOR CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS PROTECTING. THE MARKET
ACCIDENTAL FOR CANDIDATES
PATIENT AND MARKET EXPANSION
BELL FOR CANNABIS OPERATOR.
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED IN
LIGHT OF THE SLOW MOVING PROCESS
FOR RETAIL EXPANSION HERE WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. THOUSANDS OF SMALL
FARMS AND BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
PUT EVERYTHING ON THE LINE TO
ENTER THE LEGAL INDUSTRY CAN'T
AFFORD TO WAIT. ANY CHEATING
INTERSTATE COMMERCE NOW RATHER
THAN WAITING YEARS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF FEDERAL
LEGALIZATION WOULD BENEFIT BOTH
PRODUCER AND CONSUMER STATE OF
ALL PATIENTS CONSUMERS SMALL AND
SOCIAL EQUITY BUSINESSES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. COORDINATED ACTION
BY EIGHT I HAVE LEGALIZED
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A SENSIBLE AND
SECURE MULTI STATE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET. TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY EXPANSION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DATING LEGAL
OPERATOR WHILE PORTING A POLICY
SHIFT TO GUIDE THE FEDERAL
CONVERSATION IN THE COMING
YEARS. CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED
DISTRIBUTOR REPRESENTED BY THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
AUTHOR FOR ELEVATING THIS
IMPORTANT POLICY AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CERA DOCKETS GOOD MORNING
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
TO CAT ON BEHALF OF THE RULE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX AS
SENATOR CAFIERO SPOKE EARLIER
CALIFORNIA HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
AN EXPORTER STATE AND SP
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX WOULD ALLOW
THE PROSPEROUS DIVISIONAL IMPORT
AND EXPORT OF CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS BY AUTHORIZING
THE GOVERNOR TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH OTHER LEGALIZED
STATES AS MANY AS EIGHTEEN
STATES HAVE LEGALIZED ADULT USE
AND THIRTY STATES ALLOW MEDICAL
USE COORDINATED ACTION BY STATES
THAT HAVE LEGALIZED CANNABIS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A SENSIBLE
AND SECURE. MULTI STATE CANNABIS
MARKET WILL PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT
FEDERAL SHIFT MANY CANNABIS
BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY AT
PARTICULARLY IN RULE PRODUCING
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA ARE
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE AND MARKET
EXPANSION IS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE SOLUTION TO STABILIZE THE
INDUSTRY AND INCENTIVIZE
PARTICIPATION IN THE REGULATED
MARKET WITHOUT MARKET EXPANSION
CALIFORNIA RISK THE COLLAPSE OF
PORTIONS OF THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
DEVASTATING MANY RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHICH CAN LEAD TO A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THE
ILLICIT MARKET IN DIRE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS TO LOCAL ECONOMIES SP
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX IS A MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF VALVE FOR THE OVER
SUPPLY OF CANNABIS AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS ECONOMY. FOR THESE
REASONS ARE C. OR C. IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIX AND- YOU'RE EITHER TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY SAYING NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MISSED
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPPED ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL. THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
WE WILL BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK
YOU TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. WE HAVE TWO LINES IN Q.
WILL GO FIRST IN LINE FORTY NINE
. THANK YOU KAREN NUMBER ASHLEY
WALKER WITH NOTHING AND ON
BEHALF OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE LINE
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS ANY FRANCO SENIOR
COMPLIANCE MANAGER WITH NABBING
A LIGHT DISTRIBUTOR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR THEY'LL FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FIRST
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS WITH
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITED TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
WE WILL HEAR FROM THEM. THANK
YOU THE STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. CAN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. THERE ARE TWO LITTLE
YES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND- I
AM SO PLEASED AT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING OUT FOR FARMERS AND
LABOR AS WELL MY CONCERN AND I'M
HOPING THAT IN THE BILL OR IN
THE FUTURE WE CAN ALLOCATE
SUFFICIENT FUNDS FROM THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT MAY COME
FROM THE EXPORT IMPORTED UP FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT. MAKE SURE THAT
WE TAKE CARE OF THEM WHERE IN
TURN THEY CAN FIGHT THE ILLEGAL
GROWERS FIGHT THE ILLEGAL
PRODUCTION AND DISTRIBUTION OF
MARIJUANA- IN AROUND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DO YOU FORESEE
THAT- THERE WILL BE ALLOCATED
FUNDS WITH THE ADDITIONAL
PROCEEDS THAT. MAY COME FROM
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY. THE
QUESTION SURE THINK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SENATOR TO LEAD
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION- THE
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE-
THE FINANCING PORTION. OR THE
TAXING PORTION OF THE MARIJUANA
MARKET NEEDS TO BE. REORGANIZED
I'VE BEEN PART OF A HEARING
WHERE WE LOOKED AT THAT AND-
IT'S EXTREMELY COMPLICATED AND
IT'S PART OF WHAT IS DRIVING
PEOPLE TO THE ELEVEN ILLICIT
MARKET BECAUSE THE TAXES ARE SO
HIGH. THAT IT'S A LOT CHEAPER TO
BUY FROM THE ILLICIT MARKET AND
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS CONCERNED ABOUT AS
WELL IS THAT IT THEY'RE FIGHTING
ON ALL FRONTS TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE AND- AND MANAGE AND PART
OF IT IS THAT TAX STRUCTURE SO I
HAVE NO. NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO RETHINK IT-
HOW WE DO OUR TAXES IT'S FAIRLY
COMPLICATED AND THAT'S NOT THE
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL BUT IT
CERTAINLY CAN BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE THAT COULD BE PART OF A
COMPACT IS THAT ADDITIONAL
REVENUES WOULD GO TO INSURE THAT
WE- ARE MAINTAINING A LIT. A
LEGAL MARKET AND THAT WE'RE
DRIVING THE ILLEGAL- PRODUCERS
OUT OF BUSINESS. BUT YOU'RE FINE
MAY. I THINK WHEN THIS WHOLE
THING STARTED OBVIOUSLY YEARS
AGO WE HAD NO IDEA THAT THE
COST. OF THAT THE INDUSTRY WOULD
WOULD BE FACING BECAUSE OF THE
TAXES AND WHAT HAVE YOU BUT WE
ALSO I DON'T THINK WE REALIZED
THE NUMBER OF IT OF ILLEGAL.
FARMS AND- IN THE STATE- NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE OTHER STAGE SO
I'M I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN TAKE
ANOTHER GOOD LOOK AT THIS AND-
AND SENATOR IF YOU WOULD.
PERHAPS IN THE FUTURE LOOK INTO
THAT TO MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS SO
WE CAN'T FIGHT DELICIOUS. THE
LEGAL- GROWERS AND- AND HELP THE
INDUSTRY DO WHAT WAS AFTER
ACCOMPLISH AND- TO MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY FOR THEMSELVES BUT ALSO
PRODUCE INCOME FOR THE STATE.
AND TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE WHO
ARE NEAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
DO APPRECIATE I HAVE ANOTHER
BILL IT'S NOT HERE TODAY THAT
THAT DEALS WITH THAT WATER
DIVERSIONS. AND UP-
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION CAUSED
BY THE ILLEGAL GROWS AND SO I
THINK IF WE PUT A NOTE ON A
NUMBER OF PIECES IN PLACE. WE
CAN DO A LOT TO REDUCE THE
ILLICIT MARKET. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU MR SURNAME ED
THANK YOU MR SACK OF A. R. I
JUST WANNA SAY BRIEFLY YOU KNOW
I AGREE A 100% WITH THE LOGIC OF
YOUR BILL I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE ARE GLAD TO SUPPORT
TODAY- IN HAPPY TO MOVE IT WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SIR
WILLIAM CENTER CAREER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. UP SIR ATTENDANCE
HERE MIKE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I HAVE A QUESTION AT THE
AUTHOR. AUTHOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
QUESTION. UP I HAVE A COUPLE
CONCERNS BUT NOT ANYTHING IN
REGARDS TO WHAT WAS DISCUSSED ON
THE ON THE FLOOR AS OF RIGHT NOW
BUT MY QUESTION REALLY STEMS
AROUND THE PURPOSE BEHIND
INCLUDING LANGUAGE TO ADD A
FOREIGN LICENSE YOU TO ENGAGE IN
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITIES.
I BELIEVE THAT'S THAT'S PART OF
THIS BILL- AND PARTICULARLY- AND
JUST INTERESTED IN KNOWING IF
YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION IN
TERMS OF. HOW MANY YOU KNOW
PERMITS ARE GIVEN OUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT ARE IN OVERDRAFT
BASINS. AND THEN THE OTHER
CONCERN THAT I HAVE REALLY A
SLASH QUESTION. IS REALLY JUST A
MESS WITH WATER I MEAN WE'VE
HEARD THAT THERE IS. THEFT OF
WATER AND A LOT OF IT IS TIED
TO. AT ILLEGAL GROWS OF
MARIJUANA. AT THAT SEEMS TO BE
FRONT AND CENTER OF THIS IF THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
SAFEGUARDS IN THIS BILL IN
REGARDS TO THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS- FIRST OF ALL IS THAT
THE- IN REGARDS TO LICENSEES.
THE BILL. REQUIRES THAT ANY
AGREEMENT THAT THE GOVERNOR
WOULD ENTER INTO ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
REQUIRE THAT ANY LICENSING
RESTRICTIONS THAT WE HAVE. ON
OUR OWN LICENSEES WOULD WOULD-
HAVE TO BE. MIRRORED IN THE
JURISDICTION THAT WERE DOING
BUSINESS WITH SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T PUT AN UNFAIR BURDEN ON
CALIFORNIA LICENSEES- WE WOULD
HAVE THE SAME BURDEN ON ANY
LICENSEES THAT WANT TO SELL
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA SO IT
IT'S A TWO WAY. TO A STREET-
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS IN
REGARDS TO THE OVER DRAFTED
BASINS ON WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
THERE ARE ILLEGAL GROWS
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE STATE-
AS- FAR AS UP. UP IN- THAT
NORTHERN MOST PART OF THE STATE
CLOSE TO OREGON ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO- THAT MEXICO BORDER AND THE
ESTIMATES ARE THAT HUNDREDS. OF
THOUSANDS. OF GALLONS OF-
ACTUALLY IT'S NOT YALA'S BECAUSE
THEY USE ACRE FEET AS THE AS THE
MEASUREMENT- ARE BEING DIVERTED
IN ORDER TO. EFFECTUATE THESE
GROWS- AND SO- PART OF THE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE IS TO HAVE A
GOOD ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO BE
ABLE TO GO IN. AND TO SHUT DOWN
THESE ILLEGAL GROWS. THAT WILL
MAKE A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN
OUR WATER SUPPLY- A LOT OF THE
WATER THAT- THAT ENDS UP IN OUR
RIVERS IS NOT. GETTING THERE SO
THE DELTA IS SHORTED. HUNDREDS
OF. OF ACRE FEET ARE HUNDREDS TO
THOUSANDS OF ACRE FEET EVERY
YEAR AND YET WE'RE TAKING FROM
WE'RE NOT DOING WATER DELIVERIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THE DELTA DOESN'T HAVE
ANY WATER SO- THIS IS ONE OF OUR
OUR SOLUTIONS IS TO- ONE OF OUR
WATER SOLUTIONS IS TO REALLY
STOP THE ILLEGAL DIVERSION
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE OF. A
MARIJUANA GROWS IN ADDITION TO
THE WATER BEING IMPACTED YOU
HAVE- POLLUTION AS WELL AS
UNREGULATED- PESTICIDES AND
HERBICIDES ARE USED ON THESE
GROSS SO THAT ALSO CONTAMINATES
THE WATER IN THE WELLS- AS WELL
SO THE THEFT WATER BECOMES
IMPORTANT THIS BILL DOESN'T DEAL
WITH THAT BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT IT IT IS CRITICAL TO OUR-
TO OUR WATER SYSTEM THAT WE- WE
STOP THESE ILLEGAL GROWS. AND I
JUST WANT TO CONCLUDE BY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE FOR THE-
ANSWERS AND- I JUST WANT TO
CONCLUDE WITH- THE SAME VARIETY.
I HAVE THESE CONCERNS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY I'LL BE NOT VOTING
FOR THIS BILL ACTUALLY. I HAVE A
BILL SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY FOUR
THAT- TOUCHES ON FOREIGN
AGRICULTURAL LAND HOLDINGS. I
THINK THAT IT COULD BECOME
INCREASINGLY MORE OF AN ISSUE
AND MORE THAN HAPPY TO YOU KNOW
WORK WITH YOU AND OTHERS THAT
ARE PART OF YOUR- OF YOUR BILL
TO BE ABLE TO KIND OF ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE. BUT- AND HOPEFULLY CAN
SUPPORT DOWN THE ROAD THANK YOU
. THANK YOU- PAN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SECOND ROW
FOR BRAINS BILL FORD JUST A
QUESTION TERMS IF I UNDERSTAND
FROM WHAT YOUR TESTIMONY THAT.
IF WE HAVE A COMPACT WITH
ANOTHER STATE THAT CERTAINLY
ANY- CANNABIS ACCOUNTS OF THAT
STATE IN THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
BE CALIFORNIA'S. CORRECT I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS THAT- DURING
INSTRUCTIONS IN TERMS OF THE-
CONTACTS IF SOMEONE WITH A GROWS
IN CALIFORNIA MAINLY FOR EXPORT
. THAT THEY ALSO HAVE TO WE WANT
TO BE SURE THEY FOLLOW
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE GROWING
AT A CALIFORNIA THEY MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS OF OUT OF
STATE RIGHT TERMS OF SELLING AND
THAT OTHER STATE THAT AT LEAST
THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW CALIFORNIA.
GOVERNMENTAL AND OTHER
PROTECTIONS SINCE THEY'RE
GROWING IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
OF COURSE IMPACTS OUR STATE EVEN
IF THERE LET'S SAY MAINLY
EXPORTING ALL OF IT TO THE OTHER
STATE AND THE CONTACT. VERY GOOD
QUESTION- THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT CHANGES AND WOULD
ALLOW- A- EITHER A GROWER OR
PRODUCER FOR PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA CAN NOT MEET
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN AN INTERSTATE
COMPACT SO- THEY WOULD HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH ALL OF OUR
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT. IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
RECEIVING STATE AS WELL ALL
RIGHT APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION I DID HEAR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE BEFORE THE BILL GETS
ON THE FLORIDA LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO PROVE COMPACTS-
SO- WITH THAT- SO HELP SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY TO ALLOW TO
BEFORE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM. THE
KNOWING SEEING NO OTHER MIKE'S-
SIR KABIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR THAT THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS TODAY. WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL BY
SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM STAFF
DIRECTOR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY SIXTY PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROTH IRA
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. CHILL OUT
I'D BE BACKER. BACKER I. DODD.
DOT I A MAN HER TADO. NO HER
TADO NARROW JONES LLEVA LEAVE
THE ICEMEN MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN I
SHOW ABODE HAN. HE AND I THE
VOTE IS EIGHT OZ ONE NO HOLD
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR WESSEL. I REMEMBER FIVE
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PROCEED IN READING THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OF
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO JUST
CLARIFY THAT- ASKING FOR SEVEN
MINUTES ON THIS BILL AND THE
REASON WHY- WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS BILL FOR MANY MONTHS NOW
AND IT'S A COMPLICATED BILL AND
- INTRODUCING THE BILL HAS
REALLY HELPED TO GUIDE US IN
TERMS OF WHERE THE BILL NEEDS
TO- MOVE. AND SO- WE ARE MAKING
SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO EXPLAIN KIND
OF THE REASONS WHY. BUT BEFORE
THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT IN
TERMS OF THE BILL AND IT'S ON-
IT'S WRITTEN. I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST. A STRIKE THE FIRST
PARAGRAPH IN ITS ENTIRETY. AND
THAT WOULD BE THE PERC GRAPH
CURRENTLY NUMBERED. ONE SEVEN
EIGHT TWO ZERO. AND EVERY NIGHT
READ NUMBER THE SECOND PARAGRAPH
CURRENTLY NUMBERED ONE SEVEN
EIGHT TWO ONE A AND B. TWO ONE
SEVEN EIGHT TWO ZERO A AND B.
NOW AGAIN THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LANGUAGE WITH THE AMENDED MATT
LANGUAGE. IS TO MAKE A CONTRACT
MORE EQUITABLE AND MORE
TRANSPARENT BETWEEN THE MAKER OF
THE CONTRACT IN THE SIGNER.
WHERE THE CONTRACT CONTAINS A
CLAUSE WHICH REQUIRES THE
SIGNER. TO ASSIGN AWAY ALL THEIR
RIGHTS TO REBATES. EMOTIONAL
PROGRAMS AND INCENTIVE INCOME AS
IT STATED IN THE FACT SHEET IF
YOU HAVE THAT AVAILABLE AND
LARGELY WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO DO
HERE YOU KNOW IT IS CALM TORE
ATTENTION THAT INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN THE RENT WITH
WITH IN REGARDS TO BUSINESSES
MAKING CONTRACTS SPECIFICALLY
FRANCHISES- WITH THEIR FRANCHISE
STORES OFTEN THERE IS A VERY-
UNCLEAR CLAUSES JUST A CLAUSE
THAT SAYS THAT YOU SIGN AWAY
YOUR RIGHTS. TO ANY- PROMOTIONAL
INCOME WITHOUT NECESSARILY
STATING HOW MUCH THAT IS AND
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF YOUR REVENUE
THAT IS AND WHEN YOU A SIGN AWAY
YOUR RIGHTS YOU ACTUALLY ASSIGN
AWAY ACTUALLY- PRODUCT PLACEMENT
RIGHTS- YOU- HE COULD YOU COULD
EVEN- SIGN AWAY IN TERMS OF-
WHAT AMOUNT OF YOUR BUSINESS
PLAN IS THAT DEDICATED TO A
SPECIFIC ENDEAVOR. WHEN THAT
HAPPENS GIVING YOU AN EXAMPLE
LET'S SAY ON VALENTINE'S DAY THE
FRANCHISE OR THE MAKER OF THE
CONTRACT AND SAY YOU HAVE TO
DISPLAY THIS PRODUCT IN THE MOST
PROMINENT LOCATION AND THAT
COULDN'T COULDN'T HAVE A HUGE
INFLUENCE AND HOW MUCH THAT
PRODUCT. IS MOVED WITH RESPECT
TO OTHERS. SO WHEN WE CAME TO.
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT A LOT OF
TIMES THESE- SIGNERS OF THESE
CONTRACTS SPEND A LOT OF TIME
MOVING PODUCTS THAT ARE NOT
SPECIFICALLY IN THEIR OWN
BUSINESS PLAN INTERESTS ARE
OFTEN WORKING. FOR THE MAKER OF
THE CONTRACT WHO MAKES QUITE A
BIT OF REVENUE FROM THE SPECIFIC
PRODUCTS WITHOUT EVER HAVING
DISCLOSED IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE CONTRACT PERIOD ALL WE'RE
ASKING IS THAT PROCESS BE
TRANSPARENT. THAT THE SIGN OF
THE CONTRACT UNDERSTAND THAT
HERE'S A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT IS- EXCHANGED THROUGH
THIS PROCESS WHEN THEY GIVE AWAY
THEIR RIGHTS THEY'RE GIVEN AWAY-
RIGHTS TO- IMPORTANT GAINS THAT
COULD HELP THEM MANAGE THEIR
BUSINESSES OFTEN TIMES IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA. OFTEN TIMES- CERTAIN
. COMPANIES THAT ARE UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF A FRANCHISE OFTEN
TIMES CAN DO BETTER IN SPECIFIC
PARTS OF THE STATE. THEN IN
OTHERS. AND THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
AT LEAST OPERATE UNDER. A
STRUCTURE THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
SURVIVE SO YOU KNOW OFTEN TIMES
THE CENTERS OF THESE CONTRACTS
ARE VERY SMALL- THESE ARE NEW-
BUSINESS PEOPLE THAT ARE OFTEN
INVESTING. THEIR THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS INTO A BUSINESS THAT IS
OFTEN TIED. TO A FRANCHISE-
ARRANGEMENT. SO THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IN
THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD WE
EXPECT TO MAKE THE RIGHT
AMENDMENTS IN TERMS OF TO- GET
TO THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE. OF
DISCLOSURE IN THE CONTRACT
SIGNING PROCESS THOSE. REBATES
PROMOTIONS AND INCENTIVES-
OFTENTIMES ARE ARE A BIG PART OF
THIS CONTRACT YET THEY'RE
SILENT. THERE IS NO INFORMATION
EXCHANGE IN THE PRIMARY PART OF
THIS PROCESS TO ACCOUNT FOR.
WHAT IS A REALLY BIG PART OF THE
OF THE BUSINESS PLAN. SO THERE
THERE'S FEDERAL LAW THAT IS
GENERAL IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
REVENUE. BUT UNDER UNDER- I
THINK AND I'M WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING OF THIS PROCESS IS THAT
MANY NEW STRATEGIES HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED TO. AVOID DISCLOSURE
INCLUDING A HIDING SOME OF THIS
REVENUE IN TERMS OF- IN IN
PROMOTIONS AND REBATES AND
INCENTIVES WHICH ARE WAY I WE
THINK AROUND FEDERAL LAW AND I
THINK CALIFORNIA. NEEDS TO STAND
UP FOR OUR OUR ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESS PERSON THAT- NEEDS TO
GO INTO THESE CONTRACTS
COMPLETELY AWARE. OF WHAT
THEY'RE SIGNING. ONE OF YOU KNOW
ONE LAST THING. THAT I'D LEFT.
AT LIKE TO ADD- JUST GENERALLY-
YOU KNOW. UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS AND I'M
ASKING THIS COMMITTEE TO KIND OF
WORK WITH ME AND I THINK THE MEN
MEN'S- THAT WE'RE PROPOSING AT
LEAST WILL MAKE THIS BILL A PAL
PALATABLE IT WILL REMOVE
OPPOSITION BUT WE ARE EXPECTING
OPPOSITION IN THE FUTURE I
THINK. THAT IT'S FAIR TO SAY.
THAT THE COMPANIES THAT STAND TO
GAIN FROM THESE PROMOTIONS WILL
WILL DEFINITELY. HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT TO SHOW
THAT THEY THERE IS A CERTAIN
INCOME THIS NOT BEING DISCLOSED
IN THE CONTRACT I'M SURE I'M NOT
I DON'T KNOW THIS FOR CERTAIN
BUT- BUT- I KNOW IN THIS PROCESS
I KNOW THEY MIGHT COME OUT AND
PUT OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL SO
WANT FULL DISCLOSURE. TO KNOW
WHAT DIRECTION WE INTEND TO
MOVE- D. LAST THING I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT I THINK IS VERY
KEY. IMAGINE YOU ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT WITH A COMPANY THAT
SAYS YOU NEED TO BUY FROM THIS
BUS SUPPLIER UNDER OUR CONTRACT
. AND AS THE SIGNER TO THE
CONTRACT I'M COMPLETELY
OBLIGATED. FROM BUYING FROM THAT
SUPPLIER I DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
UNDER THAT AGREEMENT. I HAVE TO
ACTUALLY APPLY AND GET A CREDIT
APPROVAL AND GET APPROVED SO
THE- THE UMBRELLA CORPORATION A
MAKES ME SIGNS AGREEMENT DOESN'T
GIVE ME ANY PROTECTION FROM THE
SUPPLIER DOESN'T. GIVE ME ANY
CREDIT IT DOESN'T GIVE ME THE
YOU KNOW HELP ME SATISFY THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SUPPLIER I
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS
SEPT SEPARATELY AS THE SIGNER TO
THE CONTRACT. AND ONCE I'VE DONE
THAT. THEY HAD THESE. DEALS THAT
THEY THESE BLANKET DEALS AT THE
DATE OF ENTRY INTO WITH ALL THE
SUPPLIERS. THAT GIVE THEM A
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW REBATES SO
WHATEVER PRICE I GET FROM THAT
SUPPLIER. THEY ARE GETTING A
PERCENTAGE IN THE FORM OF A
REBATE OR SOME INCENTIVE BECAUSE
THEY ARE CREATED. MARK MORE US
SALES AND ACTIVITY- I THINK-
THAT IS- WHAT FROM WHAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF SIGNERS THEY
WERE EVEN A VAGUE WHERE. THAT
THAT SITUATION EXISTED AT THE
TIME OF SOCKS SIGNING THE
CONTRACT AND I THINK THAT IS.
EXTREMELY UNFAIR IN THIS PROCESS
AND ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR IS
FAIRNESS WE WANT PEOPLE TO ENTER
INTO A CONTRACT. WITH A COMPLETE
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT'S ON THE TABLE
WHEN THEY SIGNED A CONTRACT IN
THE DECIDE TO SIGN THAT CONTRACT
WITH PROVISIONS I THINK THAT. IS
THEIR DECISION BUT AT LEAST
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW WE WOULD
PROTECT THE SIGNER. WAS- YOU
KNOW INTEREST IN MAKING SURE
THAT HE IS OR SHE- OR THEY ARE
FULLY AWARE OF ALL THE-
PROVISIONS OF THE CONTRACT AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR- GIVEN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT AMENDMENTS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE
ALL CLEAR ALL MY COLLEAGUES HERE
IN THE CHAMBER. AND WHAT THE
PROPOSED AUTHOR AMENDMENT IS
THAT I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED. IT'S FAIRLY LIMITED
IT'S SET FORTH ON PAGE THREE OF
THE ANALYSIS. THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL REQUIRES
REPORTING TO FTP WHICH THE
AUTHOR IS PROPOSING TO REMOVE.
ON PAGE TWO STRIKE LINE SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE INCLUSIVE
BEGINNING WITH THE WORDS ANY
MANUFACTURER. AND ENDING WITH
ENDING WITH THE WORDS OR OTHER
MONETARY INCENTIVE. TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THAT'S THE
AMENDMENT THAT WAS. NOTICED TO
THE PUBLIC THAT'S THE AMENDMENT
WILL BE VOTING ON TODAY IS THAT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING PERFECT. LET'S
MOVE TO ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FIRST IN THE
GALLERY ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SAYING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY SEVEN
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU TO REX
PRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR PHONE TO
ME PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE HAVE
AN ONLINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR NOW
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FOR MANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FIRST IN THE GALLERY
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES TO WITNESSES TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD- ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PROMPT NY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN WE WILL.
CONTINUE WITH THEM. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE HAVE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU SIR LET'S
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS BILL SENATOR DODD
. A YES- OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO GET SOME STUFF
SPECIFICITY HERE. YOU'RE ON YOUR
ON THIS BILL GOING FORWARD- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY TO- ALLOW IT TO- TO MOVE
ON. AND WITH THAT AND IF THERE'S
AT THE PROPER TIME MISTER CHAIR
I MOVE THE ITEM. OKAY THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DONE
SOONER WAY SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AT JUSTIN SIMPLY THANK-
THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND STAFF FOR
HELPING US. THROUGH WHAT HAS
BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT BILL TO
CONCEIVE. BUT IN THE END OUR AIM
IS TO- PROTECT SMALL BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA BY MAKING KENT
CONTRACTS- SUCH AS THE ONES I
DESCRIBE FAIR. AND SO I ASKED
THE U. SPORTS BILL TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM TAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL TWELVE
FORTY SEVENTY PASSES AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROSS. LINE ROSS I
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA- IBEATS
BACKER. BACKER I'D- DOTD I
EXAMINE. A GREEN EYED HER TADO.
HER TADO I'D JONES LEAVE A MAN.
MAN I KNEW MAN NEWMAN I ENSURE
BOTH. HE CAN. HE AND I. THOSE
NINE VOTES WILL HOLD REAL OPEN
FOR EPSON MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU. NEXT SEARCH-
BOOK WE WILL START I BELIEVE
WITH ITEM NUMBER FOR SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE.
PLEASE PROCEED IN READING THANK
YOU MR CHAIR. MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO FIRST THANK THE CHAIR IN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL I'M HAPPY TO
MAKE THE PROPOSED AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
WHICH WE BELIEVE ADDRESS THE
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS ADDRESSING
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE CLARITY TO THE LAW
SURROUNDING SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST ABILITIES TO PERFORM
FLEXIBLE ENDOSCOPIC EVALUATION
OF SWALLOWING. COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS FEES BY MAKING IT CLEAR
THAT THEY MUST RECEIVE WRITTEN
VERIFICATION FROM CERTIFIED EAR
NOSE AND THROAT DOCTOR THAT THE
S. L. P. HAS PERFORMED A MINIMUM
OF TWENTY FIVE SUPERVISED
FLEXIBLE TRANCE NASAL ENDOSCOPIC
PROCEDURES IN ORDER TO PERFORM
THESE EVALUATIONS ON PATIENTS
AND THAT THE SLP MAY PERFORM
THESE PROCEDURES AT A LOCATION
BASED ON THE PATIENT'S MEDICAL
NEEDS. AS WE ALL KNOW COVER
NINETEEN HAS HAD AN
UNPRECEDENTED IMPACT ON SERVICE
DELIVERY IMPACTING HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND THE PATIENTS THEY
SERVE SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES MEETING THE
EMERGING THING THE EMERGING
NEEDS OF PATIENTS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS PART OF THE INTER
PROFESSIONAL TEAMS. SLP SO PEAS
HAVE A VITAL ROLE IN PERFORMING
FEES EVALUATIONS TO INFORM
DYSPHAGIA MANAGEMENT THIS
FEATURE OR SWALLOWING
DYSFUNCTION CAN LEAD TO POSSIBLE
LUNG INFECTIONS LIMITING A
PERSON'S FOOD AND LIQUID CHOICES
FOR SAFETY WHICH CAN LEAD TO
REDUCED OVERALL QUALITY OF LIFE
AND EVEN DEPRESSION. THESE
ASSESSMENTS AND SWALLOWING ARE
NECESSARY TO ASSESS. THEIR NGO
DYSPLASIA AND DEVELOPING
APPROPRIATE INEFFICIENT
TREATMENT PLAN QUESTIONS HAVE
ARISEN IN THE FIELD REGARDING
THE EXTENT OF THE AUTHORIZATION
NEEDED BY ANY YOUR NOSE AND
THROAT DOCTOR AND WHETHER IT IS
A ONE TIME AUTHORIZATION BASED
ON THE SLP COMPETENCY OR IF THE
AUTHORIZATION IS REQUIRED EVERY
TIME. AND S. L. P. HAS TO
PERFORM ONE OF THESE PROCEDURES
THIS HAS RESULTED IN SOME
INSTANCES WITH AN SLP NOT BEING
ABLE TO PERFORM THE NEEDED
EVALUATION OR NOT BE ABLE TO
PERFORM IT IN THE LOCATION BASED
ON THE PATIENT'S MEDICAL NEEDS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CALL FOR THE F.
P. FEES PROCEDURE TO BE
PERFORMED IN MULTIPLE SETTINGS
HAS GROWN TO INDEPENDENT MAKE
DUE TO THE NUMBER OF POET
PATIENTS WHO HAVE HAD TO BE INTO
THE IT INTO BAITED. JOIN ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND HELP
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
IS JENNIFER KISNER AS AS I NEVER
DRINK IS WITH THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL THE CALIFORNIA SPEECH
LANGUAGE HEARING ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR MS CONSIDER MS
RODRIGUEZ PLEASE PROCEED. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY. HELLO
MY NAME IS JENNIFER KATHERINE
I'M A CURRENT BOARD CHAIR ALEXA
SALICORNIA SPEECH LANGUAGE AND
HEARING ASSOCIATION I HAVE BEEN
A SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST OR
SLP FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
HAVE BEEN BOARD CERTIFIED IN
FOLLOWING FOLLOWING DISORDERS
FOR OVER THIRTEEN YEARS. I'M A
CLINICAL SPECIALIST AT STANFORD
HEALTH CARE'S MOST LIKE
DISCIPLINARY HAVE NOT CONCHOLOGY
CLINIC AND I'VE WORKED THERE FOR
ALMOST TWENTY TWO YEARS I
COLLABORATED IN ADDING FLEXIBLE
ENDOSCOPIC EVALUATION OF
SWALLOWING A PIECE OF THE
DIAGNOSTIC AND TREATMENT TOOL
INTO MY FACILITY OVER TWELVE
YEARS AGO AND I PERFORMED A
NUMBER OF FEES. IN OUR CLINIC
DAILY THIS IS A LOW RENT
INVALUABLE TOOL TO ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO OBJECTIVELY
EVALUATE A PERSON FOLLOWING
FUNCTION MAKE A PROBATE
RECOMMENDATION FOR DIET AND
DIVIDE THE DELIGHT. OKAY THERE'S
PREFERRED PROVIDER THE MORNING
FOLLOWING EVALUATION AND
TREATMENT YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
READING AND FALLING. ACROSS THE
LIFE. PLEASE EXAMINATION WITH
THE- IN THE LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. AND REQUIRED CALM THAT
THE SMALL DIAMETER. WITH THE
NOTE IN ORDER TO. WROTE WHAT UP
THE PATH THE NOSE YES OF BY THE
PATIENT WITH FOOD IN MY- MIX OF
THE CALL CONTRAST. TO ABOUT THE
STATE. AND EFFICIENCY OF THEIR
SLOW FROM. A LITTLE OVER THIRTY
THAT CAN BE FOR IN ANY MEDICAL.
FOR THE PATIENT FLOW. TO OBJECT
ABOUT FOLLOWING. SENATOR FOR
FIFTY THREE WERE CLARIFY
EXISTING LAW WITH REGARD TO HOW
SO PLEASE THE REQUIRED. ONE
THREE THE CLARIFICATION WOULD
ALLOW MORE EMPATHY. THE
PERFORMANCE WELL RESPECTED ARE
THERE BY HITTING MOST OF OUR
PATIENTS. WHEN THEY NEED IT IN A
COMPLETE MEDICAL FORM. THE
CONCLUDE THAT IS NOT LIMITED TO
I CAN'T REHABILITATION AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OR
EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS ARE IN
PLACE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY IS AN HONOR TO
PHYSICALLY ON A TOPIC THAT I'M
PASSIONATE ABOUT. THANK YOU
MA'AM IS ROD REGUS. HELLO THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
CONNOR. LET THEM TO BEACH WHEN
WE FOOTBALL FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
AND MEMBER OF THE OF DIRECTORS
THE CALIFORNIA BEACH LANE
HEARING. BEFORE FIFTY THREE
CLARIFY STATUE TO ALLOW COOKIES
PERFORM. THAT ARE LOOKING. BASED
ON THE CASE NEEDS. CURRENT FIFTH
PROCEDURES ARE. PERFORMED
HOSPITAL AND- CLINIC SETTING DUE
TO THE THAT RESTRICTED EGGS ONE.
THIS BILL ALSO CLEAR THE PROCESS
FOR AN FLP TO REPEAT. FROM AN
EARLIER IN COLLEGE. HE THE
KITCHEN IS PROVIDED AFTER THE BE
PERFORM THE FACT. THAT THERE. ON
FILE BE THE VALUABLE TO WHICH WE
THIS BILL WE COULD. EVALUATE
TREAT. ORDERS WITH THE DIRECT AT
THAT. THAT IS WHAT LED ME TO
PAINT IN AND OUT. PROGRAM AND A
LARGE TRASH OF SYSTEM IN THE
CENTRAL. SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
THE PROGRAM WE CONSISTENTLY
PERFORM APPROXIMATELY FORTY EXAM
TOMORROW. AND MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE IN THE PATIENT'S
POINT OF CARE. GIVEN THE
PROFOUND IMPACT YOU CAN HAVE FOR
PATIENTS WHO FOLLOWED ORDERS I
FOUND THAT NOT BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS SERVICE TO PATIENTS
WHO LIVE IN RURAL AREAS. COULD
BE FRUSTRATING AND PROBLEMATIC
FOR THEM AND FOR ME. IN ADDITION
PATIENTS WHO UNDERGO THESE
PROCEDURES MAY RANGER LEVEL
MOBILITY. AUTHENTICATION CAN
MAKE A ONE A TWO HOUR DRIVE TO A
LARGER CITY WALK INTO A CLINIC
OR HOSPITAL TO HAVE THE
PROCEDURE PERFORMED. OTHER
PATIENTS MAY HAVE DEBILITATING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT MAKE
TRANSFERS EXTREMELY
UNCOMFORTABLE AND WERE
IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO MENTION COSTLY
IN TERMS OF TRANSPORTATION AND
RELATED EXPENSES. BY ALLOWING A
FEW TRAINED SLP TO PERFORM THE
PROCEDURE DIRECTLY AT THAT SITE
IN A SETTING THAT IS BASED ON
THE PATIENT'S MEDICAL NEEDS. WE
CAN OFFER THE SERVICES THAT SO
MANY UNDERSERVED PATIENTS ARE
GOING WITHOUT. SERVICES THAT CAN
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR OVERALL HEALTH AND QUALITY
OF LIFE. BUT STILL A LOT MORE AS
A PPP TRAINED AND COMPETENT TO
COMPLETE PEACE. AND REACH
UNDERSERVED AREAS SUCH AS THOSE
WITHIN THE FAMILY. BALANCE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NOW LET'S TURN TO. OTHER
SUPPORT WE- AND GALLERY. SAYING
NONE LET'S MOVE TO WITNESS
WAITING VIA THE TELECOM OF
MODERATOR FEW PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH A- WAITING TO IN SUPPORT OF
SO BILL FORTY FIFTY THREE WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN USE YOUR PHONE WE PRESSED
ONE OF THEM ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO LINES FOR SUPPORT IN
Q. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR MANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
FIRST. OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY SEEING NONE MOVING
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THEM. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE WE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. WE
HAVE NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE- BILL
BACK TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
BY MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR PAN-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- FISHY
THE BILL A SEARCH- BOTH. ENDS
THE WHITE CLEAR FIVE SANDERSON
FROM THE ANALYSIS THAT THE FEES
WAS ONLY WOULD ONLY BE PERFORMED
AT THE ORDER OF A LICENSED
PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON WHO
HOPEFULLY WILL BE EVALUATING FOR
ANY CONTRA INDICATIONS AND NOT
ORDER IT IF THERE'S A
CONTRIBUTION AT THE TIME. IS
THAT CORRECT. I'M SORRY ONE MORE
TIME THOSE- SO ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS IN THE BILL THAT THE
FEES PROCEDURE WOULD ONLY BE
PERFORMED ONLY UPON ORDERS OF A
LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON.
SO AND THEREFORE HOPEFULLY THAT
LICENSED PHYSICIAN SURGEON WOULD
BE EVALUATING IF THERE'S ANY
CONTRIBUTIONS WERE PERFORMING
THE PROCEDURE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR PATIENT. AND I WILL
LET MY WITNESSES ANSWER THE
QUESTION FOR YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO THERE SO MY RESPONSE TO
THAT WOULD BE THAT WE WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AS A TEAM SO- I
ALSO WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
PATIENT WAS APPROPRIATE IN
RECOMMENDING REQUESTING THE TASK
TO GET AN ORDER FROM THE
POSITION- IF THAT PATIENT HAD
ANY- CONTRA INDICATIONS WE WOULD
NOT DO THAT TASK WE WOULD MAYBE
DO A DIFFERENT TACT OR WAIT.
TILL A DIFFERENT TIME- SO WE
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO MAKE
THAT DECISION. OKAY BUT JUST TO
CLARIFY ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS THE BILL SAYS THAT
PROCEDURE. IS ONLY GONNA BE
DONE. ONLY UPON ORDERS OF A
LICENSED PHYSICIAN SURGEON YES.
OKAY THAT'S I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE I THINK THAT
HELPS ALSO ADDRESSED THE
CONTRIBUTION ISSUE THAT WAS
RAISED AND ANALYSIS AS WELL
BECAUSE- WELL CERTAINLY I THINK
THE SPEECH LANGUAGE- JUST- OF
COURSE ALSO EXERCISE THEIR OWN
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT EVALUATING
APPROPRIATE MESSAGING PROCEDURE
AT THE TIME SO WOULD. THROUGH
THE ORDER THE POSITION ALSO TAKE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY BEING SURE
THEY'LL HAVE A CONDITION THAT
PREVENTS THE SAFE. PERFORMANCE
OF THAT PROCEDURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PENN COACH ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP CENTER BOOK WITH YOU THE
TROUBLE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE CLARIFICATIONS PROVIDED BY
THIS BILL MEANS THAT MORE
PATIENTS WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THE SERVICES THEY NEED IN
SETTING BEST SUITED. TO THEIR
NEEDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NIGHT OUT THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY THREE. SURVEILLANCE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BETTER STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE
DEEP PASSES AMENDED AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RAW ONLINE ROSS
I'M MELINDA'S ARCHULETA- SO WHAT
I'D BE. B. I. BACKER BACKER I'D
DODD. DOT I EGGMAN A GOOD MAN HI
HER TADO. HER TADO I'D JONES
LIBA LIBA ICEMEN. MAN I KNEW MAN
NEW MAN I I'D SHOW BOGUS I'M A
SHOW VOGUE HI IN HERE AND I.
BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROPE OF REPS AND MEMBERS. SO
LET'S MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY ONE
HEALING ARTS BOARDS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN VERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY
ONE S. B. TEN THIRTY ONE
REQUIRES HEALING ART BOARDS
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS TO REDUCE THE RENEWAL
FEE FOR INACTIVE LICENSES TO NO
MORE THAN HALF OF THE FEE FOR
RENEWAL. OF AN ACTIVE LICENSE
LICENSE PROFESSIONALS WHO
RECEIVE THEIR LICENSE YOU'RE
FROM A BOARD UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
MAY CHOOSE TO TEMPORARILY PAUSE
THEIR PRACTICE AND APPLY FOR AN
ACTIVE LICENSE AT THE TIME FOR
RENEWAL WHILE ON INACTIVE STATUS
A LICENSEE IS ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR LICENSE WITHOUT BEING ABLE
TO PRACTICE THEIR PROFESSION.
AND WITHOUT HAVING TO MEET
LICENSE RENEWAL REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING CONTINUATION EDUCATION
COURSES. DESPITE THE REDUCED
NEED FOR THE LICENSEES
DESIGNATED BOARD TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OVER THEIR WORK THE
RENEWAL FEE ASSESSED ON AN
INACTIVE LICENSE IS TYPICALLY
THE SAME RATE AS THE FEE
ASSESSED ON AN ACTIVE LICENSE E.
WE THE WORSENING. SHORTAGE AMONG
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ESPECIALLY
DUE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IT IS CRUCIAL THAT THE
STATE PROVIDE. FINANCIAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR WORKERS WHO
CHOOSE TO TAKE A TEMPORARY PAUSE
ON THEIR PROFESSION. ON AN
INACTIVE LICENSE PROVIDES FOR
LONG TERM FLEXIBILITY AND ALLOWS
WORKERS TO USE THE HIATUS FOR A
MULTITUDE OF REASONS INCLUDING
RECOVERING FROM BURNOUT STARTING
A FAMILY OR TAKING CARE OF A
LOVED ONE WITH A LONG TERM
HEALTH ISSUES. ALTHOUGH INACTIVE
STATUS PROVIDES FOR FLEXIBILITY
LOGISTICALLY IF RENEWAL FEES ARE
NOT REDUCED AS COMPARED TO AN
ACTIVE STATUS LICENSE IT MAY
HINDER WORKERS FROM BEING ABLE
TO MAKE THE FINANCIAL DECISION
TO GO ON INACTIVE STATUS.
MOREOVER MAINTAINING AN INACTIVE
LICENSE MAKES FOR A MUCH EASIER
TRANSITION BACK TO ACTIVE
LICENSE STATUS AS COMPARED TO A
LICENSED PHYSICIAN TRANSITIONING
THEIR LICENSE FROM DELINQUENT OR
RETIRED STATUS. BY REQUIRING THE
RENEWAL FEE FOR AN ACTIVE
LICENSE TO BE NO MORE THAN HALF
THE AMOUNT OF THE FEE FOR
RENEWAL OF AN ACTIVE LICENSE FOR
HEALING ART BOARDS. S. B. TEN
THIRTY ONE WILL PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE LICENSEES WITH
FINANCIAL RELIEF AND
FLEXIBILITY. IT WILL ALSO
INCENTIVIZE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CHOOSE TO TAKE A TEMPORARY PAUSE
ON THEIR PROFESSION TO GO ON
INACTIVE STATUS RATHER THAN
DELINQUENT ALL RETIRED. WITH THE
ON GOING HEALTH CARE LABOR
SHORTAGE THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A
MORE IMPORTANT TIME TO ENSURE
THAT THESE PROFESSIONALS DO NOT
CHOOSE TO GO ON DELINQUENT OR
RETIRED STATUS RATHER THAN
INACTIVE STATUS SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF THE COST. I HAVE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT LINDSEY COLOR
WORN ON BEHALF OF THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MA'AM
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS ONE OF THE CALL
WILL RING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE TRIP REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THOUSAND
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY CALIPH AT
CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TEN THIRTY ONE BECAUSE IT
WILL REDUCE COSTS FOR HEALING
ARTS LICENSEES- AND MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PRACTITIONERS TO RE
ENTER THEIR PROFESSION WHEN AND
IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSISTANTS
WHICH ARE REGULATED BY THE BOARD
OF OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY. MAY
CONSIDER OR CHOOSE TO APPLY FOR
AN ACT OF LICENSE FOR ANY NUMBER
OF REASONS. AND THE NAME OF THE
STATE WITH PLANS TO RETURN TO
CALIFORNIA. OR THEY MAY SUSPEND
THEIR LICENSE TO CARE FOR A
FAMILY MEMBER- OR JUST TAKE A
BREAK FROM THE PROFESSION.
HAVING THE OPTION TO MAINTAIN OF
A LICENSEE IN ACTIVE STATUS IS
INVALUABLE FOR THESE LICENSEES.
AND NECESSARY FOR OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. AS THE STATE IS IN
THE MIDST OF A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE- BECAUSE RESUMING
PRACTICE FROM AN ACTIVE LICENSE
IT'S EASIER THAN TRYING TO RE
ENTER THE PROFESSION OF A
LICENSE AS WELL. LAST M. SO
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE CURRENT
AUTHORIZATION A LOT TO ALLOW FOR
AN ACTIVE LICENSES WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE RECENT STATUTORY
CHANGES. THAT ALLOW HEALING ARTS
BOARDS TO CHARGE LESS FOR AN ACT
OF LICENSE FEES. AND WE DO
BELIEVE AS THE TEN THIRTY ONE
TAKES THIS A STEP FURTHER AND IS
NECESSARY IMPROVES ON EXISTING
LAW. BY CAPTAIN CAPPING THE AN
ACTIVE LICENSE YET 50% OF THE
ACTIVE LICENSE B. I'M JUST FOR
O. T. PRACTITIONER'S LICENSE
FEES HAVE INCREASED MULTIPLE
TIMES IN RECENT YEARS. MOST
RECENT INCREASES JUST LAST YEAR
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND PAIN
EXISTING LICENSE FEES. M. IS
ALREADY A FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR
MANY O. T. PRACTITIONERS AND
OTHER HEALING ARTS PROVIDERS. TO
ENSURING THAT THE AN ACT OF
LICENSE BECAUSE LESS THAN THE
ACTIVE LICENSE RENEWAL FEE WILL
HELP RENEW RENEW AT EASE THIS
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP FOR LICENSEES.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB TEN THIRTY
ONE ENERGY DRIVE AND I'D ALSO
LIKE TO NOTE THAT I REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM ELIXIR. FROM ANY
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NO. OTHERS
WITNESS. LETS ME TO WITNESS.
WITHIN TESTIFY IN VIA THE- OR
THIS MATTER. FEUD PLEASE PRESS.
ANYWAY WAITING. IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY ONE WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
ONE AND THEN THERE- PLEASE. WE
HAVE NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW LET'S MOVE TO-
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS RATHER
IN MOVE TO HEARING FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
V. IN THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
HE WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WHEN IT DOES FIND A
POSITION OF SENATE BILL TEN
THIRTY ONE. WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH THEM. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO USING OUR
TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. WE HAVE
NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE CHAMBER OF SIR EDMUND.
THANK YOU ANNA THANK YOU TO THE
CENTER FOR BRING THIS FORTNIGHT.
SINCE CENTER SITS ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND THIS- THIS
PERFUSED GENERALLY DONE UNDER
THE SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS I'M
WONDERING WHY DO A BILL VERSUS
JUST LOOKING AT THIS IN THE
SENSE THAT PROCESS. BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW BUT WE WOULDN'T WANT
ANY AM ANYMORE TO TAKE A BIG HIT
AS WE KNOW THE LICENSE FEES
PAYS. FOR THE OVERSIGHT. I'M NOT
THE EXPERT EXCELLENT QUESTION I
THINK THE REASON WE'RE PUTTING
THIS FOURTH RIGHT NOW IS BECAUSE
OF THE URGENCY OF IT WERE JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT GOES
THROUGH IN AND- MORE EFFICIENT
AND- AND- WAY- SPEEDIER WAY I
SHOULD SAY- AND I THINK THE
REASON FOR IT RIGHT NOW. THE
REASON WE'RE MOVING IT THROGH
IS BECAUSE THERE'S SUCH A NEED
RIGHT NOW WITH- THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE BEEN HAVING
ACROSS THE FIELD WITH THE
HEALING HEARTS. WITH PEOPLE
BEING BURNT OUT IN BEING- JUST.
JUST OVERWHELMED THERE WE
THOUGHT WHAT A GREAT WAY TO HELP
THOSE THAT ARE IN NEED RIGHT
NOW- IN OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
TO BE SURE TO HAVE THE TIME.
INSTEAD OF. COMPLETELY
RELINQUISHING THEIR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE THEIR WORK ARE YOU
GIVING UP ON THEIR PROFESSION TO
ACTUALLY GIVING THEM A BREAK- AT
THIS TIME. THE DECISION PROVIDE
EXTRA BREAK IT JUST PROVIDES A
REDUCTION OF COST POTENTIALLY.
EITHER AN ACTIVE FEES YES IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE ASKING I'M
SORRY SENATOR EDMUND I GUESS I
WAS ASKING. BUT I AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR POSITION OKAY
YOUR POSITION THANK YOU. HOW IS
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. SEEING NONE OF CENTER
TO- DOCTRINE PLEASE THANK YOU
SEARCH ABOVE. EIGHT- I THINK YOU
KNOW THERE ARE CONCERNS RAISED
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE BOARDS
BUT I ALSO HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO N. COURSES DURING
OUR SUNSET REVIEW ONE OF THINGS
WE DO LOOK AT WE LOOK AT THE
VARIOUS BUDGETS OF THE BOARDS
INCLUDING HOW MUCH THEY SPEND ON
ENFORCEMENT RIGHT- SO- I THINK
IT'S- I THINK THE BILLS WORTH.
LOOKING AT I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS THAT THE 50% SHOULD SHOULD
REALLY BE PERHAPS MORE ADJUSTED
FOR THE FACT THAT. YOU MADE THE
BOARD SAID THEY HAVE TO STILL
SPEND OF COURSE MONEY FOR
CERTIFICATION AND SO FORTH THAT
WE WOULD WANT TO LEAVE THAT.
AMOUNT INTACT BUT SAY THAT WELL
SINCE YOU'RE AN ACTIVE. THE
ENFORCEMENT PARTS- WHICH THINGS
WHICH ARE USING SOCIAL PRACTICE.
AT THAT EXPENSE WOULD BE
REDUCTIONS SINCE THAT WOULD NOT
BE THE BURDEN ON THE POOR
FACILITIES AN ACTIVE- TO THAT
DEGREE. IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
MIGHT BE OPEN TO LOOKING AT WE
WILL BE OPEN TO LOOKING AT THE
FEE WE LOOKED AT 50% JUST
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT THAT WOULD
BE. A CONSERVATIVE. JUST THE
HALFWAY POINT AS TO THE COST
SINCE THERE'S NOT. ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN DOING AND ANY
OVERSIGHT. WITH THE WITH THE
INACTIVE FEES IN COMPARISON TO
SOMEBODY THAT IS ACTUALLY
ACTIVE. THAT'S WHAT WE CAME UP
WITH THE FIFTY WE JUST THOUGHT
IT WAS A NICE COMPROMISE MID
MIDWAY. SAY WASN'T. FULLY THE
FUNDING D. E. S. THE BOARD. BUT
ACTUALLY GIVE THEM SOMEWHAT OF A
FEAT AND ALSO GIVING US A BIT OF
A- A BREAK TO OUR OUR- THANK YOU
. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SIR I WILL SAY THIS I
DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
AN INACTIVE STATUS WHEN YOU HAVE
A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL OR
SOMEBODY IN AN OCCUPATION SO
THAT THEY CAN. TAKE A BREAK OR
DO SOMETHING ELSE WITHOUT.
FORFEITING OR RELINQUISHING
THEIR LICENSE AND THEN HAVING TO
START THE PROCESS ALL OVER AGAIN
WHETHER IT'S TAKING OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD EXAMS OR TAKING A
LOOK OF STATE BAR EXAM OR AN
ACCOUNTANCY BATTERY OF
ACCOUNTANCY EXAMS I ALSO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT IF YOU HAVE AN
ACTIVE STATUS TO SET THE FEES.
UP PROPERLY AND I SUSPECT IT'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL SO I
WOULD JOIN- MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
PAN AND ASKING YOU TO TAKE A-
CLOSER LOOK AT THIS SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVED OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY- HI I HAVE TO ALSO SAY I
WAS. SINGULARLY UNIMPRESSED.
WITH THE BOARD OR BOARDS THAT
SAY THEY HAVE TO CHARGE THE
INACTIVE. LICENSEE THE SAME FEE
AS AN INDIVIDUAL WITH AN ACTIVE
LICENSE SINCE IN ACTIVE STATUS
MEANS YOU ARE NOT USING YOUR
LICENSE. HENCE THE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITY. BY ITS VERY NATURE
MUST BE. PRETTY LIMP LIMITED SO-
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THIS AGAIN SHOULD MOVE
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TO TRY TO.
TO MAKE THIS A BIT MORE PERFECT
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE'S
ANYTHING HERE WE DO THAT'S
PERFECT. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY ONE'S
CENTER ARCH WHAT IS MOVE THE
BILL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY ONE DO
YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RALPH. RALPH I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D BEAT.
BEACHSIDE BACKER BACKER I'D DODD
. DAUGHTER HI A MAN A GOOD MAN I
HER TADO FURTADO I JONES JONES
I. LEIVA LEVI MEN. MAN I KNEW
MAN NEWMAN I'D SHOW A BOGUS I'M
A SHOW ABOUT A GUY PM HAND I.
BILL HAS THIRTEEN VOTES. THE
CLOSER ROLE IN THIS BILL THE
BILL IS OUT. SENATOR BOOKER ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN ZERO SEVEN. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS. I THIS IS
A BIPARTISAN BILL AND IT WOULD
ESTABLISH A DEDICATED HUB WITHIN
COPE IS TO RAISE AWARENESS FOR
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP. ASSIST ALL
TYPES OF BUSINESS OWNERS IN
NAVIGATING RESOURCES FUNDING FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FEASIBILITY
STUDIES OR DISPARAGE THE
EXISTING BUSINESS STARTUP IN
TRANSITION PROCESS EMPLOYEE
OWNED BUSINESSES COMMONLY FORMED
AS HE STOPS EMPLOYEE STOCK
OWNERSHIP PLANS. AN WORKER CO
OPS HAVE PROVEN BENEFITS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THEY
GENERATE MORE JOBS PER YEAR THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN EXPECTED
ABSOLUTELY OWNERSHIP IN THE LAY
PEOPLE OFF AT FAR LOWER RATES
AFFECT EMPLOYER BUSINESSES WERE
FOUR TIMES AS LIKELY TO RETAIN
EMPLOYEES DURING THEIR- THIS IS
THE WORST OF THIS RECENT
PANDEMIC. AS IN OTHER
RECESSIONS. THE RIGHT QUALITY
JOBS A VOICE IN THE WORKPLACE
AND FOR EACH STOPS ROUGHLY THREE
TIMES THE RETIREMENT ASSETS. AS
COMPARED TO A NON STOP COMPANIES
. THESE BENEFITS ARE PROVIDED
FOR MORE EQUITABLY IN TERMS OF
RACE GENDER ECONOMIC STATUS-
THAN OTHER. PLANS UNFORTUNATELY
FEW ADVISORS LENDERS STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES AND BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
TOPIC. EVEN PRESIDENT REAGAN IN
THE EIGHTIES SAID EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP IS THE FUTURE OF FREE
PEOPLE. BUT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
FACE INTO A CRISIS BOTH THE
LINGERING EFFECTS OF THE
SHUTDOWN AND THE SILVER TSUNAMI
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT. THE DEBATE
THESE ARE BABY BUSINESS SRGB
BOOMER BUSINESS OWNERS WER AT
OR NEAR RETIREMENT AGE WHO OWN
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYING ALMOST FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE. A SHOCKING 85%
OF BUSINESS OWNERS DO NOT HAVE
SUCCESSION PLANS MANY MANY
COMPANIES MAKE CLOSE OR SELL A
NON LOCAL BUYERS. WHO ALSO COULD
RELOCATE AND CUT JOBS. WE TAKE A
BEST PRACTICES FROM OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE DONE THIS COLORADO FOR
EXAMPLE HAS RECENTLY CREATED. AN
OFFICE OF EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP.
AND SOME CITIES HAVE DONE A
GREAT JOB. A COALITION OF
SUPPORT INCLUDING DOZENS OF
CALIFORNIA SHOPS AND WORKER
QUOTE COOPS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. AND THREE GHOSTBUSTERS
SPONSORS THE WORK COALITION.
RAJIT EQUITY AND OWNERSHIP
AMERICA MI FOUR CO AUTHORS
CENTERS AT FORTINO PORGES OR
TROUBLED AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING- OVER SIXTY BUSINESSES AN
AVERAGE STUDENT ADVERTISEMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
WE'VE BEEN REGULARLY IN
COMMUNITY- COMMUNICATION WITH GO
BIZ. CAL O. S. P. A. AND THE
FOREIGN FINANCE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO WITH. TWO SPEAKERS ONLINE
WHO SHOULD BE READY. THANK YOU
SENATOR MY UNDERSTANDING IS YOU
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES OF- AS YOU
KNOW YOU YOU H. W. AND PROJECT
EQUITY YES HERE TO TESTIFY.
PLEASE PROCEED GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
REQUESTED HELLO I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH AT S. C. I.
U. U. H. W. WEST HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN OH SEVEN S. CI U.
U. H. W. IS A LABOR UNION OF
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE WORKERS
PATIENTS AND HEALTH CARE
CONSUMERS. OUR MEMBERS ARE
FRONTLINE CAREGIVERS INCLUDING
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
DIETARY ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES
AND NURSING STAFF WHO AIM TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
BY PROVIDING QUALITY CARE FOR
ALL PATIENTS EXPANDING ACCESS TO
EXCELLENT AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
IMPROVING LIVING STANDARDS FOR
ALL WORKERS. WE'RE VERY PROUD
MEMBER OF THE WORKER OWN
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA COALITION
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE. THE COALITION IS
COMPRISED OF STATE AND NATIONAL
EXPERTS ON WORKER OWNERSHIP.
WORKER OWNED BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZED LABOR. WE CAME
TOGETHER IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
KNOWING THE EXISTING PRESSURES
FROM THE SILVER TSUNAMI OF BABY
BOOMER BUSINESS OWNERS. WHO ARE
AT OR NEAR RETIREMENT AGE WOULD
ONLY BE FURTHER COMPOUNDED DUE
TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. EVEN
BEFORE COVERT THERE WERE NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES AT RISK OF CLOSURE IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THE OWNER IS
NEARING RETIREMENT AND LACKS A
SUCCESSION PLAN. THESE ARE NOT
BUSINESSES CLOSING DUE TO UNDER
PERFORMANCE. MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES WILL CLOSE ALL
TOGETHER OR SELL TO NON LOCAL
BUYERS WHO ARE LIKELY TO
RELOCATE OR CUT JOBS. THIS WOULD
HAVE A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT BY
ELIMINATING JOBS THAT WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES DEPEND ON.
ALL SIMULTANEOUSLY REMOVING FROM
LOCAL COMMUNITIES BUSINESSES
THAT PROVIDE POOR SERVICES AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY
. WORKER OWNED BUSINESSES HAVE
PROVEN TO BE RESILIENT BUSINESS
MODELS THAT PROVIDE BETTER PAY
AND BENEFITS. ASSET BUILDING
THROUGH PROFIT SHARING
RETIREMENT SAVINGS AND SHARED
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP ENHANCED JOB
SECURITY STABILITY AND WELLBEING
FOR WORKERS. DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
IN THE RECENT PANDEMIC WORKER
OWNED BUSINESSES WERE LESS
LIKELY TO LAY OFF WORKERS AND
WERE ABLE TO RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY THAN THEIR TRADITIONAL
BUSINESS COUNTERPARTS. WE SEE
THESE MODELS ESPECIALLY
COOPERATIVES AS INCREDIBLE
PATHWAYS TO HELPING CREATE A
MORE EQUITABLE ECONOMY. AND
STRENGTHEN WORKER VOICE
ESPECIALLY FOR UNDERPAID WORKERS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. SB FORTINO
SEVEN ESTABLISHES THE NECESSARY
FRAMEWORK TO HELP EXPAND WORKER
OWNERSHIP. AND FURTHER THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO PROACTIVELY
RETAIN BUSINESSES AND SUPPORT
THE FUTURES OF WORKING PEOPLE.
MOST GOVERNMENT SERVICES ARE
DESIGNED EITHER TO SERVE A
BUSINESS OWNER OR ENTREPRENEUR
OR WORKERS. HAVING A CENTRALIZED
HUB WITHIN THE STATE GOVERNMENT
CAN BRING SAT TOGETHER THESE
PARADIGMS. GOVERNMENT SUPPORT
FOR WORKER OWNERSHIP ISN'T NOVEL
THE FEDERAL MAINSTREET EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP ACT WAS ENACTED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MANDATING THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT WORKER OWNERSHIP.
PROMPTING NEW AND CONTINUED
SUPPORT IN A NUMBER OF STATES
INCLUDING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. MAKING ORDERS OUT OF
EMPLOYEES FITS THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT OF
CALIFORNIA THE WORKER CENTERED
VISION OF ORGANIZED LABOR. AND
BUILD A MORE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY
FIT FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE- I
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HILLARY A BELL CO
FOUNDER AND CHIEF POLICY AND
IMPACT OFFICER PROJECT EQUITY.
WE ARE A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
BASED IN OAKLAND WITH A MISSION
TO INCREASE ECONOMIC RESILIENCY
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THROUGH EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP. OUR
WORK INCLUDES EDUCATING BUSINESS
OWNERS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
PARTNERING WITH DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS AND PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASISTANCE TO HELP
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSES TRANSITION
TO EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP INCLUDING
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF THE NEW
EMPLOYEE OWNERS. WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORED SB FORTINO SEVEN.
DURING MY TWENTY YEARS IN THIS
FIELD I'VE SEEN EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP CREATE TRANSFORMATIVE
BENEFITS FOR SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
AND ESSENTIAL WORKERS. FOR
EXAMPLE SERRA VEGAS IS A SINGLE
MOM IN UNION CITY WHO BECAME A
CO OWNER OF THE BAKERY WHERE SHE
WORKS. HER FIRST PROFIT SCHERING
CHECK INCREASED HER ANNUAL
EARNINGS BY MORE THAN 20% AND
BECAME THE FIRST MISTAKE THAT
SHE AND HER SON EVER HAD. ALMOST
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIKE
SERRA WORKING COMPANIES THERE
THAT ARE AT RISK SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEIR OWNER IS AT RETIREMENT
AGE. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT MANY
BUSINESS OWNERS ALREADY KNOW
ABOUT AIR WHO CAN CARRY ON THEIR
LEGACY AND KEEP JOBS IN PLACE.
THEIR OWN EMPLOYEES. I CAN TELL
YOU DOZENS OF SUCCESS STORIES OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES LIKE
SERRA'S THAT WILL THRIVE FOR
YEARS TO COME BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOW EMPLOYEE OWNED. BUT WE NEED
THOUSANDS OF THESE STORIES NOT
DOZENS. I URGE THE STATE TO
INVEST IN SCALING THIS WELL
PROVEN BUT UNDER UTILIZED
APPROACH TO ECONOMIC INCLUSION
AND COMPETITIVENESS. I'VE
AUTHORED MANY REPORTS ON THE
TOPIC INCLUDING THE CASE FOR
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP WHICH
COMPILES DECADES OF RESEARCH ON
ITS BENEFITS. BOTH IN WORKER
COOPERATIVES AND COMPANIES THAT
ARE MAJORITY OWNED BY EAST TOPS.
SENATOR BECKER SPOKE VERY WELL
TO THOSE MANY BENEFITS SO I
WON'T REPEAT THEM- SEVEN
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND COUNTIES
IN SEVERAL STATES HAVE
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
BUSINESS RETENTION AND THE VALUE
OF EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP. AND HAVE
DEPLOYED THE STRATEGIES WE ARE
ASKING THE STATE TO SCALE UP
THROUGH SP FORTINO SEVEN.
FUNDING EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
EDUCATION AND SUBSIDIZING
FEASIBILITY STUDY ASSESSMENTS.
S. B. FORTINO SEVEN ALSO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A NATIONAL LEADER IN
THE FIELD OF EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
BY TAKING THE ESSENTIAL STEP OF
CREATING A CENTRAL HUB WITHIN
GOLD IS. TO STREAMLINE EFFORTS
ACROSS MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND
CREATE SUSTAINABLE AND EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE OR
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN OH SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THOUGH LET'S SEE IF THERE ANY
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SENATE BILL FOURTEEN ZERO
SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN WITH THEM.
THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
AGAIN ONTO ON FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. WITH
AN OPERATOR ME ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU.
NOT MINE AS LINE NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS BACK ANYMORE WHILE ON
BEHALF OF APOLOGY AND BEFORE THE
BELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BERNARD NORTHERN LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU THEN
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FOR MANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FIRST. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE LET'S MOVE BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MR
OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUALS WENT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN ZERO SEVEN. WE
WILL CONTINUE WITH THEM. TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. GANNETT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. WE HAVE
NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR NOW LET'S
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SENATOR
DODD. A YES- I APPRECIATE THE
BILL'S AUTHOR SENDING ME- SOME
MORE INFORMATION ON THIS-
REGARDING THE COLORADO YOU KNOW
ISSUE AND I DO THINK THAT THERE
ARE SOME. SIGNIFICANT MERIT HERE
I BUY MY ONLY CONCERN IS WHETHER
OR NOT. YOUR WHOLE DO- THE THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT WITHIN GO THIS IS
REALLY APPROPRIATE YOU LAID OUT
A NUMBER OF THINGS IN YOUR IT IS
IN THE STAFF ANALYSIS THAT MADE
A LOT OF SENSE WOULD BE I'D LIKE
TO SEE THE AUTHOR WORK ON SOME
OF THOSE THINGS BUT ALL THE
SUPPORTING THAT TODAY THERE-
THIS BILL MOVE ALONG. THANK YOU
SENATOR DIED ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. SINGLE
MICROPHONES UP CENTER BACK OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
SHOULD I THINK- THE COMMENTS IN
THE WITNESSES- I AM SUPER
EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL I.
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER DOGS. OF
QUESTIONS WE ARE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH GO BIZ AND WITH- OS BA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SIR DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
ZERO SEVEN SENATOR DODD WAS UP
FIRST. MOTION MADE BY SENATOR
DODD THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. BETTER STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
F. B. FORTINOS SEVEN DO YOU PASS
AND RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS RALPH. RALPH I
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
I'D PLEASE.B. I. ALL RIGHT
BACKER I'D DODD. DOT I MIN HEY
MAN I HEARD HATO. JONES JONES I.
LEIVA LEAVE A I'D MADE IN MAINE
HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I I'D SHOW
ABODE AND SHOW VOGUE IPN HE AND
I. BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES AND
THAT BILL IS. WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THE BOOK BILL OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER.
COLLEAGUES WHO WERE NOT IN THE
CLOSING THE ROLES IN FIVE
MINUTES. YEAH. BECAUSE I THINK
WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL START AT
THE TOP AND WE WILL- CALL THE
BILLS. AND LET YOU VOTE AND THEN
WE WILL WAIT TO SEE IF ANYONE
ELSE WANTS TO COME DOWN AND-
CAST A VOTE. STARTING WITH THE
FILING OF NUMBER ONE SENATE BILL
NINETY SIX TO SENATOR JONES. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS ELEVEN TO ZERO
SURE VOTING- ONLINE MADAM
STAFFED RECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MELINDA'S BEATS B. X. I. A
SHOWBOAT AND SHOW BOTH I.
THIRTEEN ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN. FILE IN NUMBER TWO SENATE
BILL.
SO THAT WILL GO OVER THAT BUT
YEAH. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
PHOTO NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL
NINE NINE FOR SENATOR JONES
CURRENT VOTE IS TEN TO ZERO SURE
VOTING- I. MELENDEZ BETH. B. I.
A SHOW A BOGUS BUT SHOW VOGUE
IPN. VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO. AND
THAT MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM
FILE NUMBER I DON'T NUMBER THREE
SENATE BILL. ONE ZERO THREE ONE
TEN THIRTY ONE SENATOR BOOK THAT
BILL IS OUT VOTE IS THIRTEEN
ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE.
SENATOR JOE BLOW BOAT IS TWELVE
ZERO CURRENT VOTE YOU'RE VOTING-
I. STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MELINDA'S.
JONES JONES I. RODE HIS
THIRTEENTH ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
. FILE IN NUMBER FIVE SENATE
BILL TWELVE FORTY SEVEN SENATOR
HUESO CURRENT VOTE IS NINE TO
ZERO SURE VOTING EYEING THEM
STEP DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
UPS MEMBERS. MELINDA'S BEATS.
JONES LLEVA LEAVE A I. VOTERS
TURNED TO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WELL I REMEMBER SIX SEVEN BILLS
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX AND RECOVER
EURO CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT TO
ONE SURE VOTING HI MADAM STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MELINDA. BAIT EIGHT NO
EGGMAN EIGHT MEN I JONES JONES
NARROW A SHOW ABOUT OPEN. VOTERS
NINETY THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
MMHM ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN ZERO SEVEN SENATOR
BOOKER. CURRENT VOTE IS TWELVE
ZERO SURE VOTING ALLY AND STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MELINDA'S HER TADO. THE VOTE IS
TWELVE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE IN NUMBER EIGHT SENATE BILL. FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE. RALPH
KERN VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO SURE
VOTING I'VE PHYSICALLY ABSENT
MEMBERS. MELENDEZ PLEASE B. I
DON. DON I HER TADO. MIN. MAN I
UNTIL A BOGEY. UNTIL A BOGEY I.
BOAT IS TWELVE ZERO. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. FILE IN NUMBER NINE
SENATE BILL. FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR. CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO
SURE VOTING A STEP DIRECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE OF SOME MEMBERS
. MELINDA'S PLEASE. B. I DON.
DONNA HI HER TADO MIN MAIN I A
TOWBOAT. A SHOW A BOGO I.
VOTERS. TWELVE ZERO THIS MATTER
IS OUT. FOLLOW NUMBER TEN SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE NINE TO ZERO SURE VOTING I
. INSTEAD OF DIRECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MELINDA'S FAITH. EIGHT I HEARD
TOMORROW A SHOW A BOGUS A SHOW
ABOUT A GUY. DODD DOT I. VOTERS
TWELVE ZERO THE MATTER IS OUT.
WELL AM NUMBER ELEVEN SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO BUT
INSTEAD OF DIRECTLY WITH YOUR
VOTING- AMEN STEPPED RECTOR
PLEASE FILL THE UPS AND MEMBERS
. MELENDEZ BAIT. DOT. DOT HI HER
TADO. HER TADO HI A TO A BOGUS.
A SHOW ABOUT HI. VOTERS TWELVE
ZERO MATTERS OUT. FOLLOW HIM
NUMBER TWELVE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO SURE VOTING I
MANAGED AFTER A TRIP PLEASE CALL
THE OFFICE AND MEMBERS MELENDEZ.
BAIT B. R. I. BACKER. BACKER I
HATO FURTADO I A TO A BOGEY AND
SHOW BOTH I. PHOTO. THIRTEEN
ZERO- THE MATTER IS OUT. AND THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS FELL IN THIRTEEN
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE AND FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE A CURRENT
VOTE TEN ZERO SURE VOTING HI.
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE AND
MEMBERS MALIGNED DOES. BAIT B.
FIVE BACKER. A SHOW ABOUT A SHOW
ABOUT A GUY. VOTERS TWELVE ZERO
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TO. I DIDN'T HEAR YOU I. HE
CLOSED IT SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR
YOU SAY I THOUGHT YOU WERE
SAYING OFFICE. THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS IF POSSIBLE.
THANKS EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE CERTAINLY TODAY WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS ADJOURNED.